[Music]
the reason that the economy was so sick
it's not the coronavirus
it's because of everything the
government did before the corota virus
why do you think that argument of
blaming capitalism is so attractive the
government needs to bail out individuals
the government has to bail out the
states the government has to bail out
corporations
with what money the government doesn't
have any money we're about to find out
the hard way that the most expensive way
to pay for government is through
inflation
this is going to end in complete
catastrophe
big government's the problem no it's
bailout no we gotta look at the gdp no
we gotta look at our debt ratio no we
gotta look at the gold standard
everybody is broke nobody has savings
and then
this crisis comes we can't kick this can
down the road anymore if we're spending
trillions on the military why can't we
spend money on sending checks to people
the idea is two wrongs make a right but
they don't so now they want to make
college
even more expensive by making it free
why do we bail out the too big to fail
we elected donald trump and then as soon
as he got to washington he became
part of the very swamp that he wanted to
drain trump wasn't expecting a pandemic
though who cares about the stock market
it's a bubble
are you saying biden's going to be trump
i think the odds are in my favor
are you willing to bet an ounce of gold
people don't vote for freedom
they vote for free stuff we need to stop
spending money we need to figure out a
way to pay up our debt and in doing so
we need to raise the taxes
no one's going to vote for this person
this thing is going to implode and it's
going to implode
soon the party is going to end the
dollar is going to crash
and we're going to see the cost of
living go through the roof
[Music]
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we gain no value to haters how they run
homie look what i become
i'm the one
[Music]
so look i've had a different economist
in the past whether it's arthur laffer
whether it's
even ray dalio or recently daniel
demartino booth but when we had daniel
the martino booth
we put a comment saying who else would
you like to see i'd say a thousand is a
small number
thousands of people requested
my guest today who has a scenery con
senior economist and a market strategist
he's got a lot of strong opinions
he's an entrepreneur uh he's somebody
that was in the financial industry he's
still in the financial industry and he's
doing some incredible things and has
always got strong opinions we'll talk to
him today about it
and with that being said petership
thanks for being a guest on
valuetainment
oh patrick uh thanks for having me on
you know i caught your interview
with uh danielle dimitino booth a good
interview i've known her for
uh quite a long time i guess we speak at
some of the
same conferences uh you know we'll see i
think the next one i
i may go to is in new orleans and we'll
see we'll see if that one actually
happens
live you know with all the cove but it's
hard to say but you know if you see art
laughter again
i let them know i'm still waiting for my
penny
i don't know if you know about that that
bet that we made on kudlow's show
back in 2006 but i he's welched on that
bet
so uh but he's been saying some decent
things recently now i gotta at least
give him a little credit you know i've
been hard on laffer
but at least recently he's been in the
correct camp he's been critical
of the stimulus of of the cares act of
the ppp
so you know better late than never you
know peter
if we do this just just for some of the
audience some of the viewers that don't
know who you are
ideas okay where do you position
yourself economically if you were to say
i consider myself xyz i'm a capitalist
i'm a libertarian i'm a pro gold
can you kind of say that and then i want
to go to a couple of different areas
from there
well i'm all of those things i mean i
believe in free market
okay so which is limited government uh
sound money uh you know i believe in the
principles
that the nation was founded on uh by
by our founding fathers um and you know
laissez faire
uh you know the the idea of america as
a nation of individuals rugged
individuals self-reliant
uh the idea of the concept of federalism
uh where the federal government is
supposed to live within its
constitutional restrictions where the
federal government
does very little it's predominantly uh
concerned about international
affairs uh keeping us safe from uh
you know international threats uh but
all the domestic affairs are left to
state and local governments uh so the
federal government is very small does
very little
uh and and even the state governments
don't do a lot
um but but obviously we have the
complete opposite of that now we have a
very
powerful a very strong a central
government
uh the antithesis of what the founders
envisioned for this nation
uh we don't have sound money at all uh
we have fiat money just
paper money they create a thin air that
has no value we have
more of a centrally planned economy
where we rely on bureaucrats to make
decisions
uh about what they think is best instead
of relying
on adam smith and the invisible hand and
and the wonders of of the free market
and
you know the problem is we have
interjected so much
socialism into the market-based economy
that we once had the capitalist economy
and we've created tremendous problems
particularly the problem that we're in
right now uh
but what happens is whenever the
government uh
mixes socialism in with capitalism and
creates a problem
it's always capitalism that gets the
blame for the problems that socialism
created
and then the argument is always well we
need even more socialism
which is what's happening now when
everybody says oh we need to bail
everybody out we need to stimulate the
economy everybody needs government money
the reason that the economy was so sick
it's not the coronavirus
it's because of everything the
government did before the coronavirus
so the government crippled the economy
the solution isn't to find a bigger
crutch
a government crutch it's let's eliminate
all these government programs
make government smaller so that the free
market
can solve these problems but we're doing
the opposite we have made government
much bigger
which is why this recession depression
is going to be much
deeper than it otherwise would have been
had the government actually
uh you know made itself smaller and
reduced the burden that it
imposes on the economy instead of what
it's doing now
peter why do you think two things by the
way one uh the government smaller we'll
get into that in a minute but the first
thing you said was
you know when when we face problems like
this the immediate reaction is to blame
capitalism where in reality socialism
the reason why what caused it
why do you think that argument of
blaming capitalism
is so attractive well because it's
it's politicians right politicians want
to get votes
and the way they get votes is by
promising to do something to give
somebody something that they don't have
uh and so if a politician says look the
solution is let the free market work
uh there's no votes in that and of
course you know wall street everybody
that
that you know that made mistakes and
borrowed too much money
they all want to get bailed out they
don't want to lose money i mean this is
what happened
after the 2008 financial crisis i mean i
made a name for myself
on national television for four or five
years
predicting the 2008 financial crisis
and i said it was going to result from
the
bursting of the real estate bubble and
all of the debts that would go bad
when that bubble popped so i talked
about the problems in the financial
institutions
i talked about the in the bankruptcy of
fannie and freddie
and what all that would mean but i
blamed
both the housing bubble that i was
witnessing
and the financial crisis that i was
forecasting
on the federal reserve on alan greenspan
for his response to the 2001 recession
the bursting of the dot-com bubble
911 i said the fed lowered interest
rates too much
when they went to one percent they kept
them there too long
and they raised them too slowly and
during that time they were inflating a
housing bubble
that was also uh being fueled
by the government agencies fannie and
freddie
both guaranteeing mortgages and buying
up mortgages
and also we were fueling an
international demand
for mortgage-backed securities by
keeping interest rates so low everybody
was stretching for yield
and as the fed kept interest rates so
low
and real estate prices got too high
consumers were levering up they were
borrowing against their houses
and buying more stuff so our trade
deficits were going up hitting record
highs
and then what was happening was all of
our trading partners were recycling
their surpluses back into the mortgage
bonds uh and to get yield
so we had this huge bubble that the fed
inflated in combination with the moral
hazard of fannie and freddie
and i said this is going to be a
disaster when the bubble pops it's going
to be the worst recession since the
great depression
we're gonna have trillion dollar
deficits we're gonna have 10
unemployment
everything that i said was going to
happen happened in fact
you could watch on youtube my mortgage
banker speech from 2006
i spoke in front of 3 000 mortgage
bankers laying out the financial crisis
the housing
collapse the subprime i actually went
there raising money for the hedge fund
that we had set up
to short the subprime market in o6 so i
i really knew what was going to happen
but then the more important part of it
and i put it all in a book
you can see the the book crash proof uh
uh you know on my bookshelf the original
one
was not 2.0 but crash proof that came
out in february of 07
but was written largely in at the end of
0.5 the first half of 06 right the book
was finished by
by the middle of 06. and it just takes a
while to uh to
to come out but what i what i predicted
was
not only were we going to have this
financial crisis
but that after the bubble popped
the government and the fed instead of
acknowledging
their fault and inflating this bubble
and doing the right thing
they would double down on the failed
policies they were going to
slash interest rates they were going to
print all this money
and they were going to uh reflate the
bubble or attempt to reflate the bubble
i i thought that they would fail in
their attempt i thought the foreign
currency markets and the gold market
would put a stop to the party uh
but i was wrong on that in that we
actually succeeded
in doing something that i didn't think
was possible but we actually inflated a
bigger bubble
than the one that popped in 2008 and
that's the one
that just popped and in fact the air was
coming out of that bubble
last year i predicted when the federal
reserve
first announced that it was going to nqe
and that it was going to normalize rates
i said at that time
that the fed was lying that it could do
neither that it would never be able to
normalize rates it would never be able
to shrink its balance sheet
that if it tried it would have to abort
the efforts prematurely
that it would go back to zero that qe4
would be bigger than qe one two and
three combined
i was saying that for years in fact on
day one when ben bernanke
uh went to congress when they first said
hey are you monetizing the debt
and ben bernanke said no no no this is
all temporary
we're not monetizing the debt we're not
you know a permanent source of
government funding
it's an emergency as soon as the
emergency is over we're going to sell
these bonds
i said at the time that ben bernanke was
lying that the fed could never sell
those bonds
that they had checked us into a monetary
roach motel
uh that they could get in they could
never get out and we'd have more qes
than rocky movies
so i was right about all that and now
we're at the end game we're at the real
crash that was the topic of my
my my uh later book because
we can't kick this can down the road
anymore i mean what the politicians want
to do
is they never want to deal with the
problem they
want to postpone the consequences by
kicking the can down the road even if
doing that
makes the problems worse and makes the
consequences even more severe
let me ask you care about that because
they'll deal with that in the future and
then when they catch up to the can
they kick it again the problem is we are
out of road at this point they don't
know that yet they're gonna they're
trying to kick it down again
but this time we're gonna get a dollar
collapse we're gonna get a sovereign
debt crisis
the party is going to end uh all the
inflation that they're creating now
which is unprecedented in scale
right they've done it before but just
not in this scale
the amount of inflation which is the
money printing uh
is off the charts the deficits are
exploding
in a way that i've never seen uh uh and
this is going to end in complete
catastrophe and people are complacent
because we got away with it after the
2008 financial crisis
we're not going to get away with it
again so so then here's a question
how much i asked the question saying why
do they constantly blame capitalism
and and socialism is what is the benefit
of doing that why
why why blame an economical system
that's
that's proven that's work to constantly
say black you know capitalism is getting
a black eye capitalism is getting a
black guy capitalism doesn't work
we need a new form of capitalism how
much of that argument is right and how
much of it is just
you know finding something to blame we
don't need a new form of capitalism we
need to go
back to capitalism the type of
capitalism that we've been practicing
has been the problem because it's
capitalism and name only
right it's socialism or maybe more
accurately fascism
if you understand the true meaning
because uh fascism is a form of
socialism so is
uh communism and what we've been doing
is more of a mussolini type fascism
obviously than communism but that is the
problem
with the economy that economic system
but
a in order to do the right thing first
you have to have the politicians and the
central bankers
admit that they did the wrong thing in
the past which they never
want to do they never want to fess up to
their mistakes
and say we did this right we interfered
with capitalism
and that's why we have this problem so
number one they never want to do that
but if they finally embrace capitalism
and say okay
we're going to swallow this bitter
tasting medicine because ultimately
recessions is the free market's way
of fixing the mistakes that the
government and the central banks create
because the mistakes are made during the
bubble during the boom
right everybody feels great during the
boom but that's when all the
malinvestments are made
all the misallocations or resources are
occur then when there's a bust that's
the free market's attempt
to restore order to create balance in
the economy
so it's viable and sustainable uh and so
you have to allow a recession to run its
course
even though it's painful even though it
means people lose jobs
investors lose money uh you know loans
go into default
companies that are not viable go
bankrupt and what happens in that
cleansing process is that resources are
freed up
to be reallocated more efficiently and
more productively that includes labor
and and capital and land uh but that
process
obviously is painful to certain people
uh
and you know in in the immediate you
don't know uh
how it's going to end and so the
politicians are under tremendous
pressure
to do something about it oh people are
unemployed let's provide them with money
businesses are going to fail let's bail
them out instead of doing the right
thing
by allowing the businesses to fail right
and allowing
uh all the the the you know the
reallocation of labor and capital
they interfere but the interference is
what makes it worse it exacerbates
uh the downturn and it me
it means that we don't get a real
recovery the recovery that we had
following the 2008 financial crisis was
phony
it was just a bigger bubble than the one
that popped
had we done the right thing in 08 and
let
real estate prices continue to fall let
foreclosures happen
let banks fail and not bail them out
let the bad actors be punished right let
new
owners step up and buy in bankruptcy
a lot of these companies that were so
mismanaged and allowed
you know consumption to come down and
savings to go up which is the underlying
problem that the fed created
is a nation where we have too much debt
and not enough savings
so instead of allowing uh the savings to
be rebuilt
and balance sheets to be improved we
inflated an even bigger bubble
than the one that popped and so we
didn't have a real recovery
and that's why the economy is so
vulnerable now
to this uh covet 19 crisis
because as i said the economy was sick
long before
the virus infected it and the air was
already coming out of the bubble
because the fed tried to do something
that was impossible which was
normalized interest rates with an
abnormal amount of debt
they got everybody you know hooked on
the drug of cheap money
and then tried to withdraw the drug from
the market and then obviously
we went into withdrawal at the end of
that's when the fed came back and said
okay
more qe we're going back to qe we're
going back to rate cuts
but then we got the coronavirus
and what everybody is focusing on is the
virus
the virus is the pin the problem is the
massive bubble
that that pin pricked and in fact i said
it was
already kind of pricked that pin just
put a gaping hole
in that bubble and now the air is coming
gushing out
but the reason that the economy is so
vulnerable is because we're broke and
levered to the hilt
the reason that nobody can do without uh
income for
a few weeks or a few months is because
everybody has debt to service
right corporations are levered to the
max they've been borrowing all this
cheap money
from the fed they've been using it to
buy up their overpriced stock
so they didn't have any any any savings
individual households
are leveraged to the max on cheap
consumer credit
they got mortgage debt student loans
auto loans credit card debt they're
living paycheck to paycheck
you take that paycheck away they can't
pay their rent
they can't pay their mortgage they can't
pay their debts the same thing with
local governments
uh state uh municipalities have been uh
you know
making promises they couldn't keep
they've been borrowing all this money
they have underfunded pensions
they got nothing saved for a rainy day
then it pours
so the states are broke and then the
federal government of course
is we've been running massive deficits
even when the economy was supposedly
recovering
so everybody is broke nobody has savings
and then this crisis comes right and and
a lot of people want to talk about
well this is like world war ii it's the
opposite of world war ii
because when world war ii hit nobody got
bailed out
nobody got a stimulus check every got
everybody got a bill
for world war ii first of all 16 million
men had a fight
they had to leave their homes and they
had to go to europe and japan
but the people who didn't fight had to
finance the war
the the government massively increased
taxes when the war began
uh fewer than three percent of the
population even paid income taxes
before world war ii uh once it started
better than 30 percent of the people
started to pay income taxes
uh because we imposed withholding taxes
for the first time as part of the
victory tax
but not only did we triple taxes on the
middle class to pay for the war
but the government borrowed money
directly from the minimum middle class
by selling war bonds and so everybody
stopped spending
and was giving all their money to the
government in either taxes or in direct
loans and where were all the customers
where were all the businesses
who now had a big drop in their sales
right i mean restaurants i mean who was
eating in restaurants when
you know everybody was fighting a war
where everybody was you know loaning
money to the government i mean
all of these businesses suffered
consumer spending imploded
uh during the uh second world war yet
not a single business got bailed out
no no no the government relied on the
people
to pay for that war now we're all we all
believe that
the government needs to bail out the
people the government needs to bail out
individuals
the government has to bail out the
states the government has to bail out
uh corporations with what money the
government doesn't have any money it's
the people that support the government
not the other way around but we're
pretending that the government can
support the people
by using a printing press that all we
have to do is print money
and nobody has to work nobody has to
produce we can have all this stuff for
free
well we're about to find out the hard
way that the most expensive way to pay
for government
is through inflation through printing
money that's what we're doing and we're
about to relive
uh the lessons of history uh because a
lot of countries have tried this before
and it has ended in disaster every time
it's been tried
peter let me ask you this so in the
world of bodybuilding i ask bodybuilders
tell me
what are the most important qualities
for somebody to win mr olympia and
they'll say number one
is you got to have good genetics it's
number one if you don't have it forget
it anybody can go out there and do it
you're not going to win the stroller
then they say number two is uh diet then
they'll go number three is
training then they'll go number four is
cardio whatever they'll tell me on
a height is one of them you can't be too
tall because your muscles are long
etc etc when when somebody when the
average person turns on the news they'll
say oh my gosh it's you know
big government's the problem no it's
bailout no we got to look at the gdp no
we got to look at our debt ratio no we
got to look at the gold standard no we
got to look at the fiat currency you
know we got to look at
you know this if if the average person
is watching this to say what are the
most
important numbers to look at you know
gary keller wrote the book the one thing
like you always go to the one thing
that's the most important important
thing to look at
what what are the most important numbers
to look at that can
predict what's going to be happened in
the future what would you say some of
those data
some of those numbers are yeah and i'll
i'll mention that in a second but first
you know when you're talking about
uh you know the bodybuilder and how to
in getting in shape and that's a good
analogy because i often
use that to you know describe the
economy
because the government is saying hey
we're going to win mr olympia
and we're just we're not going to train
at all we're not going to exercise at
all
and we're going to stuff our face with
junk food yet expect to win
that that competition because you know
when somebody is
out of shape and overweight the solution
is not to eat more
you know it's to go on a diet it's to
exercise
but if you go to a person who is out of
shape and is
and doesn't eat well and you say look
you know this is what you need to do
uh they don't want to do that because
it's going to temporarily
uh you know cause some discomfort in
their daily routine
i got to stop eating what i want i got
to wake up early and i got to exercise i
don't want to do that
that's hard i'd rather just you know lie
in bed right and
so um that's the problem the economy
you know the fed is you know the we're
out of shape
and and what the fed said is just eat
more junk food because it feels good to
do that rather than
doing the right thing i mean the right
thing right now for the economy
is for the government to shrink right
the government is a burden on the
economy
that everybody must bear so the correct
solution in a recession
is to shrink government cut government
spending
and free up those resources that were
being
uh consumed by government and free them
back into the economy
to be used productively so you cut
government spending
you cut government regulation and you
let interest rates go
up so when interest rates go up we get
more savings
and when you have more savings you have
more capital investment that's what the
economy needs more savings and more
investment
we don't need more debt we don't need
more consumption
that was part of the problem excess
consumption financed by debt
and we don't need to make government
bigger government was already too big
but we are doing the wrong thing right
now right we are simply
increasing the problem we had a a a debt
crisis
in 2008 what was the government solution
to have more debt well if we had a
crisis in 08
because we had too much debt and if we
have so much more debt now
how much worse is this crisis going to
be i mean greenspan only kept rates at
one percent for about a year and a half
and then it took about another year and
a half to get back up to five
we had rates at zero for six seven years
we never got him back up to normal it
took like three years to get back to
two and a half percent and then it took
a year to get back to zero and we're
never going off zero now
until the market forces us which answers
your question
what do people have to look at you got
to look at the price of gold
which is already going up but at some
point it's going to go up much faster
you got to look at the exchange rate of
the u.s dollar
versus other currencies now right now
the dollar is stable
right but it's not going to stay stable
for long at some point the dollar is
going to fall
and then you got to look at long-term
interest rates right wait for long-term
interest rates to really start spiking
higher
that is ultimately going to happen now
if you wait for those three things to
happen
a big move up in gold a plunge in the
dollar
and a sharp increase in long-term
interest rates
it's too late to do anything about it
financially i mean you've missed the
boat
what you've got to do now what i've done
personally what i'm helping my clients
do
is get out of u.s financial assets get
out of the dollar get out of us bonds
before that crisis but once the market
finally reacts right ben bernanke or not
ben bernanke jerome powell
uh yesterday said that now is not the
time he was at a press conference after
they left rates at zero
and he was asked about the debt are you
worried about the debt which is
exploding at an unprecedented rate
and his response was no i'm not worried
now's not the time to worry about the
debt
of course he's never worried about the
debt that's the problem and we never
want to fix the debt when times are good
and then when times are bad we say we
can't worry about the debt now and so we
got to make the debt bigger and bigger
but when the market finally worries
about it because you know if the central
bank is worried about the debt
then that's good maybe the markets don't
have to but if the
chairman of the federal reserve says the
fed is not worried about the debt
and actually is encouraging the
government to take on more debt
that's when the markets ought to really
worry about that debt
because it's going to run out of control
and when the markets put a break
on the debt right by we're not buying
these treasuries we're not holding these
dollars
and you start to see uh the dollar
crashing a bond price is moving up
right the stagflation really comes fully
into play
then that's when the party's over right
that's when the fed
is forced to make the decision that it
has been reluctant to make
for a decade or two and it keeps kicking
the can down the road
but when it finally has no choice
because we're about to see a sovereign
debt crisis
we're about to see hyper inflation where
the value of the dollar is completely
destroyed
right and everybody you know wants to
think that we're going to get all this
government for free right we're not
raising taxes
we're cutting taxes but everybody's
getting a bailout everybody's getting a
check
and nobody is asking who's paying for it
okay government has to be paid for
now the government can fund its
operations honestly through taxation
where it actually takes money away from
some people and gives it to other people
or it can do it dishonestly the way it's
doing now through inflation
have the federal reserve create money
out of thin air and just give it to
people just spend it into circulation
but when the fed does that it's not
you're not getting that government for
free
that means that people that already have
dollars in savings
in annuities and pensions uh you know
under their mattress wherever you have
dollars those dollars
lose their purchasing power and that
purchasing power is transferred
to the people who are receiving the
government money so instead of the
government taking your money
the government is taking the purchasing
power from your money so
that's who's going to get paid i mean
you're going to you're going to be stuck
with this bill if you
if you have savings if you've got a
portfolio of bonds or you've got an
annuity or cash value an insurance
policy
or you're working for wages the value of
what you earn
is about the collapse in that the cost
of living is about to explode
and that's how we're paying for this but
the choice that the federal reserve is
going to have to make
when the markets finally take away the
punch ball that the fed should have
taken away on its own but when the
markets
force this decision on the fed then the
fed's gonna have to do one of two things
let interest rates go way up and they're
going to have to go much higher than
they would have gone have the fed let
them go up before remember
when when green when when volcker did
the right thing who was the last fed
chairman to ever do the right thing
the market put pushed interest rates up
to 20 percent i would say that
they're going to go higher this time
than 20 now
imagine that because we couldn't even
survive two and a half percent
the fed had to start cutting imagine
what happens to this over leveraged
economy
at twenty percent rates i mean even at
ten percent rates or five percent rates
imagine what happens so what would
actually happen is
massive default on an unprecedented uh
uh scale
including the us government if the
federal reserve does
the right thing the u.s government will
be forced to default on treasuries it
will not be able to pay the interest
on the debt it will not be able to
obviously pay the principal
and it will have to default on its
commitments to pay
people social security benefits medicare
benefits i mean
it's going to be a wave of defaults uh
on an unprecedented level
massive bankruptcies massive collapses
that's if the fed does the right thing
but that's the problem though i mean if
you think about that here here's what
if you think about that this is what it
seems like it's happening uh uh you said
gold exchange of rate uh us obviously
the currency and the long-term
interest rates and i'll get to a second
part of the question here
is in order for the person to do the
right thing so let's just say
we know what the right thing is to
campaign on okay so imagine i'm running
for office and this is my campaign
we need to stop spending money we need
to have the
40 of businesses that are to be you know
people that don't have the finances in
order
some of these guys need to get filtered
out we need to figure out a way to pay
off our debt
and in doing so we need to raise the
taxes we need no one's going to vote for
this person
look yes freedom capitalism liberty is a
lousy campaign slogan
people don't vote for freedom they vote
for free stuff
that is the problem look the founding
fathers knew this
that's why america was created as a
republic
they knew if we were a democracy we
would collapse so they protected us
from democracy with the republican form
of government that they created and they
and they bound the government
in the chains of the constitution and it
worked for a long time
we were incredibly free throughout the
19th century i mean the most prosperous
period of america of american history of
world history
was probably the end of the civil war to
the beginning of the first world war
that's when we had the smallest
government the purest gold standard
we really were you know following the
constitution
and and we prospered but yes you know it
is very difficult
when now everybody is voting and the
government in particular
has crippled so many people uh and now
they have the crutch
and people don't realize that they're
crippled because of the government all
they see is the government offering a
crutch
and they want that crutch and look you
know you look at look at the example
of student loans i mean this is one of
the most obvious examples
of a government credit problem i ran for
senate
in connecticut in 2010 and you know i
was against student loans i wanted to
abolish all
government guaranteed student loans on
all student loans and you know before
the government got involved in student
loans which it didn't always do it
really started with the gi bill in the
second world war
but that was just you know to help the
soldiers who were returning from the war
they really started getting involved in
the 60s so before that
you know if you wanted to go to college
you just paid for it and it wasn't
expensive
college believe it or not was not
expensive before the government came in
to help make it affordable if your
parents were relatively rich
they just wrote a check you know if they
were upper class you know
if your parents were lower middle class
or middle class
maybe you got a summer job that's what
my dad did my dad went to college
he he grew up his parents were
relatively poor uh
he worked his way through college like
most of his friends by waiting tables
over the summer
that's it he graduated college no debt
right and he you know and he lived away
from home but he was able to earn enough
just getting tips on a summer job uh to
to put himself through college but what
happened is a bunch of politicians came
to the students
in the 1960s and said you shouldn't have
to work over the summers
you should enjoy your summers you should
be go to the beach
and having fun will let you borrow the
money
right to go to college and you just pay
it back after you graduate
when you have a better job and you can
earn more money and the students look oh
that sounds great
i can have fun this summer i don't have
to work the government's going to give
me this loan now of course
without the government guarantees the
students couldn't borrow the money
because they had no collateral
what bank is going to loan money to an
18 year old you know
so uh they couldn't have got the loans
but once the government
guaranteed the loans then any anybody
could get the loans so the minute the
kids had all this money to go to college
and bid up the prices
the universities were like oh wow we can
really raise prices now because the
students can borrow the money from the
government
and and give it to us so the minute the
government started
uh guaranteeing student loans tuition
has started to explode
and then as the tuition got higher and
higher the government had to provide
bigger and bigger loans to pay for it
and then it became a self perpetuating
spiral the more money the government
made available to students
the higher the tuition got to the point
that now
the students are graduating with a
crippling amount of debt
whereas they used to graduate debt-free
when the government wasn't involved at
all
now they're graduating with massive debt
and the irony of it is you see these
democrats
right in these debates pointing to this
huge problem
without admitting that the government is
the only reason those student loans
exist
without those student loans college
would be cheap
and students wouldn't have any debt but
because of government interference
the cost of a college degree went
through the roof and because
everybody has a college degree now
they're worth nothing
before the government was involved most
people didn't go to college
a high school degree was all you needed
now because everybody goes
you need a heist you need a college
degree to do what you used to be able to
do with a high school degree
now you got to get a master's or a phd
but by the time you borrow all the money
to get that
and you're in school into your early 30s
right you're in debt up to your eyebrows
all this is because of government now
what are these guys saying are they
saying oh we really screwed up
here we had good intentions uh but the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
and now we need to get government out of
the student loan business completely
we need to have free market capitalism
working so that colleges are under
competitive
pressures to control their costs to get
customers
like everybody no no now the solution is
completely nationalize it
have the government pay for college
let's make college free
let's forgive all the loans so now they
want to make college
even more expensive by making it free
right the most expensive things are the
stuff you get
for but from the government for free so
they first they jacked up the cost by
subsidizing it
now they want to make it even more
expensive by providing it for free
they did the same thing with housing you
know they did the same thing with health
care
every aspect of the economy that the
government gets involved in
they screw it up they make the price go
up and the quality go down
whereas when the free market is involved
the opposite happens
prices go down and and quality goes up
but i got to finish the point i was
making on the choice that the fed has
either they do the right thing and let
interest rates go up
and the whole house of cards that
they've been building crashes down
or they don't do that because it's too
politically difficult
and they just print money they just
continue the qe
they bail out everybody and they destroy
the dollar and then the dollar is
worthless and then if they do that
right a hyperinflation is much worse
economically
than just a massive economic collapse
right the pain that that will inflict
is going to be far greater but because
it may happen six months or a year later
or two years later who knows
that may be the course that we end up
taking
so again everything you said let's just
say common sense let's take common sense
make the government smaller you know uh
you know figure out a way to not spend
the kind of money with school loans
where the government's not involved in
the school loans let the private folks
do it you don't get involved so we don't
have to have the
what's the number today one trillion
dollars a trillion uh
uh uh one four or one it's somewhere
around they're a trillion two or
trillion three we have college debt
right
oh yeah it's like it's more than that
yeah let's just say it's
everything you're saying common sense
somebody watching says okay
this makes sense i get it but i want to
go
solutions i want to go next phase i
talked to a guy at aig we were having a
debate because
i've been asking these guys to make some
adjustments on their technology
and they keep saying pat you know we're
working on it we're working on it this
was like four years ago finally one of
the guys who's a stud quality guy trust
them he said look you have to realize
who you're doing business with i said
what's that
he said this is aig i said i know i've
been doing business with you guys for a
decade now
he says we're so big that when you want
to launch a
new adjustment to a software or a
technology
it's not like a small business owner
entrepreneur that's nimble to say
let's make the change it's going to take
you know 60 days 90 days
yeah here's what i'm going with this let
me wrap up the question here we're
saying okay let's make the government
smaller you got seven and a half eight
million employees that are governed
employees
you got the military you got all these
people that are working
all these different epa all these
departments that you have how do you
make the government smaller on
one term or two terms so again this
leads to the next question is
you got one term two term president then
you got republican president bush senior
then you got clinton then you got bush
then you got obama then you got trump
then you got
you know you say cuomo gets elected
one philosophy doesn't stay long enough
for us to be able to pay off this that
it's about what campaigns get it gets us
reelected
so i mean that's not going to be paid
off that we have to be honest about that
we can't even solve the problems unless
we're honest about the situation so
the debts are not going to be repaid the
question is is it better to inflate them
away
or default i think default is better i
think a legitimate bankruptcy and
restructuring
is better hey look we loaded all the
kids up with debt yes
students have much too much debt we
cannot expect them to repay it
but we can't solve the problem unless we
first say okay
no more government involvement in
college we it was a mistake
uh and and and colleges are going to
have to compete in the free market for
students
no government guaranteed loans no
government direct loans we we have to go
back to capitalism
uh in order for the solutions to work
the solutions will work
now people are going to lose money
because if loans are not repaid
then the lenders are going to suffer a
loss that
has to happen but you know when when you
talk about making government smaller
yes the government's going to have to
lay off a lot of government workers that
doesn't mean those people are going to
be unemployed forever
that means the resources that were
required to employ them
are now freed up back to the private
sector the private sector is going to
use those resources
more efficiently and more productively
than the government so whenever the
government cuts spending
right and and including laying off
government workers
now the private sector has more money to
employ those workers
productively in fact a lot of government
workers not only are they not productive
they actually work reducing the
productivity of everybody else
so it's like the people who are actually
producing they are less productive
because of all these bureaucrats getting
in their way
so you know the bureaucrats are riding
in the wagon and the rest of us
are trying to pull it if the people who
are riding in the wagon
not only jump out but help us pull right
then we're going to make a lot more
progress
that wagon is going to be a lot easier
we're going to take it a lot further so
there's
there's a lot of light at the end of a
free market tunnel
but first you've got to get over that
hump of of letting voters know
that you know yes if you if you died and
exercise i know it's not going to be fun
uh but you're going to be healthier
you're going to have a better life
you're going to live longer
you know if you just do this if you just
follow this program
so capitalism uh is going to take us to
where we want to go
socialism never will it's it's a false
promise that oh we're just going to
solve this problem
with more government but you know the
other problem is you know so many
americans have been brainwashed in
government schools
they don't understand free market
capitalism
they just see the problems in the
economy and assume
that they're a function of free market
capitalism when they're not
and they think that more government is
the solution to a problem that they
don't understand was created by
government
and by making government bigger we're
just going to make the problems big
yeah but that still doesn't answer my
question for you the the the
the uh the the question about you got
something this big to want to re-haul
and change
it's not a small thing to change it's a
massive massive thing to change
and to have one president we elect who
gets up there and comes up with this
campaign to say let's do this
the number of opposition is so massive
for somebody to do this to have so many
even whether it's a republican or a
democrat or a libertarian or a third
party or whatever you want to call it
there are so many people on each camp
that are relying on lobbyists that are
relying on these people
that are how do you how do you how do
you fight those guys yeah it's look
the founding fathers refer to them as
factions and that's basically what we
have look there is an entire
establishment that is feeding off the
status quo
and so they want to perpetuate it and
they're basically like sucking the blood
out of the
the economy right you have certain
people getting rich
bleeding the rest of the nation that's
why you have this growing
divide between the average american or
the poor
and the super rich this is not a failure
of capitalism
yes in capitalism there's always going
to be income inequality and that's fine
but what we have now is an extreme
and it's not because of capitalism it's
not a failure of capitalism it's a
failure to
have capitalism it's government that is
doing this now the people who are
benefiting
from these policies have a vested
interest
to maintain them and they will pay the
politicians
in one way or the other in order to
perpetuate
this scheme and look we elected donald
trump right an outsider
not a politician who said a lot of
really good things
on the camp train trail about the phony
nature of the recovery
about the bubble he was anti-fed you
know this is cheap money this is all
artificial
i'm going to drain the swamp he actually
came at this like yes
i am an outsider i'm not a politician
i'm going to go to washington clean
house
and then as soon as he got to washington
he became part of the very swamp that he
wanted to drain
he presided over a massive increase in
government spending
uh so government got bigger under donald
trump he he went from being
a fed critic to a fed cheerleader in
fact the only thing he criticized the
fed for
was not printing enough money right not
not cutting rates enough i mean
he criticized the fed for being too easy
as a candidate and then he said they
were too tight when he was president he
wanted the fed to do everything he
criticized it for
so he became the the leader of that
swamp
and yes we got some tax cuts but those
tax cuts were a fraud
because tax cuts have to do with cutting
government spending
the the cost of government is what it
spends so government spending
is taxation every dollar the government
spends
is a dollar that we have to fund and so
when presidents
sign budgets that increase government
spending they are
increasing taxation regardless of what
they do
with the income tax rate spending is
taxation
now how are they going to pay for it are
they going to tax us today
are they going to borrow the money which
means they're going to tax us even more
tomorrow
because now we have to pay the taxes to
cover the interest
or is the federal reserve going to
monetize the debt
are they going to print more money which
means we pay for government through
debasement of the currency
through inflation now we have not felt
the full weight of the inflation tax
because we've been able to export it
because the dollar has functioned as the
world's reserve currency
we're able to run these massive trade
deficits and we could
export all the money that we're printing
and we can get products in return
so that's kept the lid on consumer
prices and allowed the fed to pretend
that even though they're creating
inflation in an unprecedented scale
that we don't have any inflation that
there's not enough of it
but that's why i said you got to watch
the dollar you got to watch the
treasuries the gold market
this thing is going to implode and it's
going to implode soon
the party is going to end the dollar is
going to crash and a tsunami of
inflation that we've been exporting
uh for years and years is gonna come
hitting us uh our shores
and we're gonna see the cost of living
go through the roof
and that is the cost of government and
then once the world no longer accepts
the dollar
and we can't run these huge trade
deficits we're stuck with all the money
we print
then we're going to feel the full weight
of that inflation tax
which means what then then we're going
to be open to the idea of changing
because every single this goes back to
what you said earlier when you said
every time there's a problem
it's another uh avenue like even right
now
uh you see this is why we need a
stimulus check this is why
the uh plan that andrew yang talked
about is effective we can't afford to
pay people a thousand dollars a month we
can't afford to pay people
two thousand dollars a month if we're
spending trillions on the military
why can't we spend money on uh spending
sending checks to people
yeah but if we can bail out these big
companies
you they need to know the whole concept
of our social i know too but
yeah the idea is two wrongs make a right
but they don't and
and we couldn't uh the bailouts are a
mistake i mean
just because we made the mistake of
bailing out the banks in oh eight
doesn't mean that we should repeat the
mistake by bailing out the airlines
or the hotels uh and just because we
made the mistake of bailing out wall
street
doesn't mean we compound the mistake by
bailing out main street why not
bail out nobody but why do we bail out
like why
do we bail out the too big to fail what
is this well because obviously
there's two reasons one is the politics
of it
you know from they're gonna the
industries that get bailed out are gonna
recycle some of that bailout money and
line the pockets of the politicians that
voted to bail them out right i mean
that's
a quick pro quo that's going to happen
but
also when it comes to economics right
you have the
scene and you have the unseen the
effects
and when a government bails out a
business
the immediate benefits to those who
receive the bailouts are there
the company is there the jobs are saved
uh and so and the people who benefit
from the bailout
uh they are known and and they will vote
for you
the but what you don't see are the
negative consequences that are widely
dispersed throughout the economy where
there's no political constituency
for that but let's take one of these
industries that get bailed out whether
it's airlines right let's say we didn't
bail out
airlines or you know any hotels or any
of these companies
the way the politicians want to present
it is that if we didn't bail out these
industries they would disappear
like oh we need airlines we need hotels
we can't just
let these countries go bank these
industries go bankrupt how will we get
around
right see that's the lie of the bailout
if the government didn't bail out the
companies
they would go through a normal
bankruptcy
during a bankruptcy the companies don't
stop operating
right they continue to operate what
happens is
they don't have to pay their debts
anymore which is why they're in
bankruptcy because of all the money they
borrowed
but they go through a bankruptcy and who
gets wiped out
the common stockholders the unsecured
creditors there are
investors who lose but the businesses to
the extent that they have value
survive and new owners come in
and more importantly they're going to be
more responsible than the owners who
failed
and the companies are not going to have
all the debt the debt gets wiped out
so now that the businesses no longer
have all the debt they can be more
efficient
they can offer a more competitive
product they can lower prices
maybe they can pay better wages because
they're not hampered with all this debt
instead we're keeping these companies
alive by loading up with even more debt
so they're going to be even less
efficient and some companies
need to shrink you know the government
is saying
we can't we have to make sure that
companies don't fire any workers
why what if they need to fire workers
what if they have too many workers
what that's why they're not profitable
because they they have to
downsize their workforce to make the
business
competitive and reflect the free market
demand
for the products they're making or the
services they're providing
if we keep payrolls bloated that is a
waste of labor resources we're
squandering those resources
we need to free up that labor to go work
someplace else where the market would
direct it
but now we're creating these zombie
companies that are wards of the state
and the cost to society of subsidizing
these businesses far exceeds the
benefits to the people who are being
bailed out but again that's the unseen
consequence
of government interference let the free
market
function and we will have an optimal
allocation of resources
and we will all collectively benefit
from a higher standard of living but we
have the government interfering and
diverting resources from where the
market wants them
to where the politics demand everybody
suffers because we have a lower quality
of living a lower standard of living
because we're increasing uh production
costs and making the economy less
efficient
so let's just say we were to make that
adjustment let's say we are open to it
let's say
we get somebody that's strong enough
that can present that to the american
people and let's just say he can
convince 51 percent of people
to say i'm with it i'm with it let's go
through this process of
allowing the too big to fail to fail
let's let's go through the process of
you know me going back to maybe i can do
100 financing on a home
maybe it goes to 60 financing on a home
if you don't have 40 percent of down
payment on a house
you probably shouldn't own a house you
probably should rent a house let's just
say we go
through alec who benefits right who
benefits from government policy
to guarantee mortgages it's actually not
the person who's buying the house
it's the person who has a house to sell
because by
guaranteeing mortgages
the government is helping to prop up
real estate prices
if there was no government guarantee
mortgages right
if individuals had to convince the bank
to loan them money based on their own
credit quality their own ability to
repay
the banks would not be willing to loan
as much money and they would want more
collateral
they wouldn't give you a mortgage with
three percent down or five percent down
they would want 20 25
down right and so if that happened
real estate prices would collapse right
so people would still be able to buy
houses they just wouldn't have to borrow
nearly as much money to do it
because the price would be lower so
maybe you can't afford a 20
down payment when the house you want to
buy is 300 000
but if the house drops to 100 000 you
could afford to pay 20
right you won't have all this debt the
beneficiary
of the policy is the guy who already
owns the house
who wants to sell it he can sell it for
a much higher price
if the government's going to guarantee
the mortgage of the buyer
but then you have a bubble you have a
phony real estate market
i want to have a real real estate market
that reflects
mark the free market not government
subsidies
uh because the government now has to
keep this this whole pyramid going
uh with more and more debt but yet it is
going to be a very
impossible uh you know political battle
because right now right
the republicans have already signed on
to socialism
they have basically agreed with the
democrats that we need big government
right and and it is it's a logical thing
right
see the the position that the
republicans have is inconsistent
logically
the republicans are saying during good
times
the profits should be uh privatized but
during bad times we need to socialize
the losses so we
we need to have low taxes and limited
government when times are good
but when times are bad we need massive
government and we have to bail out
everybody even the rich
that doesn't make any sense at least the
democrats
can have a logically consistent though
flawed argument
we need big government all the time if
we need big government during bad times
we need big government during good times
if we're going to socialize the losses
let's socialize the profits right that's
a consistent argument
that i think is going to win which is
why i think that trump is going to be a
one-termer
because i don't think he can out-promise
uh biden or whoever is the
the the top of the democratic ticket
when it's a battle between two democrats
the democrats
biden you're saying you don't think
trump beats biden no
and i thought trump was going to be
clinton very few people did at the time
um because the reason i thought that
trump could beat clinton
is because trump was telling the truth
about how lousy the economy was
and he was promising a real solution now
he's going to try to perpetuate the same
lie that didn't work for hillary
although now he's going to try to blame
the problem on the coronavirus
uh and maybe that strategy will work i
mean do you actually believe biden's
going to be trump
but at this point look i don't think the
democrat republicans can out promise the
democrats because
the election is going to be decided over
who
is going to give out the most free stuff
and i think the democrats win
that argument now what what's going to
happen is when we have a complete
collapse of the economy
if we have hyperinflation or complete
implosion and there's massive poverty
inflation is so bad that they have price
controls and the minute they have price
controls you have shortages
you have black markets i mean it's going
to be a complete disaster
then we can have a real campaign
between do we go all in on socialism is
this
ca are we so broke are we destitute are
we having this misery
and poverty right is it because of too
much capitalism
and too much greed right or is it
because of too much government
too much central planning is it the
bureaucrats and socialism
that destroyed the prosperity that
capitalism built
or did did socialism build the
prosperity and did capitalism destroy it
and so do we need to be a nation of
slaves or a nation of free individuals i
mean that's going to be the real debate
between uh uh big government and freedom
and and and hopefully uh freedom could
win that debate i don't know i mean it's
a tough call
uh you know but you're on record are you
saying biden's gonna be trump
i think well i think biden will beat
trump or if biden ends up not being the
nominee for some crazy reason
i think whoever is at the top of the
ticket uh will be trump
but i mean is it a sure thing no i mean
i think that
what's your percentage if you were to
betting menu or las vegas what's your
percentage if
i say i say i say he's 70 i think it's
70 80 percent
at least that it's going to be biden you
think 70 80
yeah because we're still going to be in
a recession
in november so you're going to have a
bunch of people voting during a
recession
and you know trump promised a lot of
people to make their lives better and
their lives are going to be worse
uh and you know are they wasn't
expecting a corona virus
trump wasn't expecting a pandemic though
but he was going to lose even without
this we were going to be in recession
even without uh the coronavirus it was
already starting the economy was already
rolling over the bubble was already
deflating
so yes this may be his only chance which
is a reason why
uh trump may be incentivized to keep the
shutdown going longer and longer
because to the extent that everything is
still shut down in november it's easier
to blame it on the virus but let's
assume that we try to restart the
economy
uh in may or june
and then we're still in deep recession
which we will be
uh by november it will be harder for
trump
to to blame the virus i mean he will i
mean i think before the virus he was
going to blame the fed
but i think the voters are just going to
blame republicans blame trump
and look they are not going to be able
to out promise
the democrats we're going to have a
bidding war over who's going to give out
the most free stuff
who do you think wins that you know i i
you know
i just think that when it's when you
have two people promising
bigger government the democrats win it's
not going to be an argument
of less government versus more
government or capitalism versus
socialism
capital socialism has already won the
debate bernie sanders is now the
mainstream of both political parties
i mean stuff that the republicans are
supporting today even bernie sanders
would have been too embarrassed to
recommend it six months ago
yeah i i don't know if i i don't know if
i uh uh see that happening because i
don't think
america is fully yet comfortable for the
concept of socialism to come in i think
it's getting a big surge
because the last generation is the
biggest generation ever you know for the
longest time
boomers were 76 million now you got a
bigger generation that's got 80 to 83
million
and they're younger you know how this
works they have to go through their
process of getting fired getting married
losing jobs losing promotions you know
and understanding what it is when uh
you're working your ass off and somebody
else who isn't through politics gets
promoted over you then you say i'm sick
of this crap you know i want to go out
there and do my own thing
we have to go through that but but this
this this is this is the part that this
brings me to as you're
uh talking about the stuff with
re-election uh as far as trump goes
you're saying trump wouldn't have won
without coronavirus you're saying
with or without a coronavirus trump
wouldn't have gotten reelected
yeah yeah i don't think that trump was
going to win in fact if you look at the
politics of it
i mean donald trump i mean he didn't win
in a landslide
he won the electoral college but if you
look at the states
that he won he won by very narrow
margins
in those states right and who were those
swing voters i mean these were probably
democrats
that were tired of being lied to by the
establishment
they knew that the recovery under obama
was phony
that it was just smoke and mirrors it
was a stock market
right donald trump called it out who
cares about the stock market it's a
bubble
the fed is doing that the economy i'm
going to reindustrialize the economy
right i'm going to we're going
the economy is is a disaster it's been
hollowed out i remember
some of those last commercials that he
ran about how the american economy had
been destroyed we had these huge trade
deficits
the trade deficits are bigger now than
they ever were before trump was elected
none of the manufacturing has come back
it's all been a lie
the manufacturing sector is as weak as
it's ever been
so none of the substantive changes that
that trump promised did we get rid of
obamacare no we made obamacare worse
that's all we did so you know and we
perpetuated the same
monetary policy that that trump
criticized so the recovery
under trump was just as phony as the
recovery
under obama and so i think the people
who were who voted for trump because
they kind of
hoped that he would be different when
they realized that he wasn't
right that he was no different that
nothing changed and then
you have a democrat promising democratic
socialism saying look
this is what's going to help right the
government's going to give you this and
give you that and do all this
those people may say okay i tried the
republicans
i tried trump that didn't work so now
let me try this
right i mean because it's always like
things keep getting worse and then you
want to vote for change
and so i thought people would want to
vote for change not more or the same
yeah it's going to be here's here's what
i predict since you've been famous for
making predictions i'm going to make a
prediction here for you okay
i'm going to join the peter ship camp
and make a prediction you said
you made some good predictions you made
some uh questionable predictions i think
you said gold was going to get to 5 000
and what was it 2012 it was at 1700
today i think it's around 1700
but this is my prediction my prediction
is
i think republicans and democrats
true democrats jfk democrats not
bernie uh democrats i'm talking like a
democrat of the 60s
that was you know they had certain
philosophies where jfk
today would probably not be a democrat
he'd be a completely different thing
politically
what about lyndon johnson well lyndon
johnson is a completely different story
to me i i i have a
different opinion on him but this this
is what i think about today this is what
i think about today
i foresee a ticket like this taking
place in the next
two to three elections here's a ticket
that i think america is going to be more
open to it than ever before
i think we're going to see a president
that's a republican with a vp that's a
dem or vice versa
a president that's a democrat and a vp
that's a republican
and they're going to come out and
they're going to say listen i'm not
we're not comfortable what's going on
right now we just decided to bring one
of each where
he and i or she and i are going to
debate it out and we're going to try to
make our best decisions because we're
not going to get a third party
perot tried to do it it didn't work i
think we may have
in the next two or three elections
somebody campaigning with a
republican president and a democrat or
vp
or some of that taking place that will
only happen once i think in a way well i
mean
but at this point there's so little
difference
between the democrats and republicans
anyway that i don't even know
how that even makes a difference there's
very little daylight i mean we have a
third party
uh the libertarians have been there for
a long time uh they're
constantly they're on the ballot usually
in all 50 states the problem is the
media
uh ignores them they don't get it their
candidates don't make it into the
debates
and so the the two parties really have a
monopoly a duopoly on power uh whether
you want to call them republic rats or
dem republicans
and so they have a vested interest in
maintaining that status quo
of really one party that's divided into
two wings
and so they're preventing any any third
parties
uh from from gaining any traction so
that is a big problem
but you know what you have to overlook
is how are we going to get from where we
are
to what you're talking about when we
have to go through this complete
economic armageddon
that is around the corner we have a date
with with destiny here
we are going to have a financial
collapse much worse than
08 much worse when it's happened now
when the fed has to make that choice
that i just described
either letting interest rates skyrocket
and letting the economy implode
in a way that we've never seen before
with massive destruction
uh layoffs bankruptcies defaults
i with no bailouts at all remember in
order to do the right thing
nobody gets bailed out even though it's
going to be much worse than it is now
no bailout no stimulus nothing the
government has to sit back
because if it doesn't have the fed you
know uh providing the money
the government has no money so the
government is powerless all it can do is
do what i said which is to cut spending
and it's going to be forced to cut
spending because it's not going to have
the money
to spend or how do we get through
hyperinflation
when we wipe out the value of our money
i mean imagine
imagine people who have millions of
dollars in savings
being destitute i mean maybe they still
have assets
that have value they have a house but
they can't afford to maintain it they
can't afford to pay
the cost of repairs because well their
savings have been wiped out
what happens when we destroy the value
of our money
so we have to get through the the this
this
uh situation either we destroy the
dollar or we have a massive economic
implosion
and of course if we destroy the dollar
the economic implosion is even bigger
so we're going to have to get through
this to get to the other
side and and so what is that process
going to look like
and what is going to emerge on the other
side is it going to be a return of free
market capitalism
that leads to the promised land of you
know a higher standard of living
or are we going to complete the road to
surf them is america going to be a
totalitarian
a nation with an all-powerful government
i mean it's a very scary
uh prospect i mean i can be hopeful that
we make the right choice
uh but you know i mean the wrong choice
is very devastating
do you think what america was founded on
it's almost a model in a system that's
uh not possible to last too long when
the country gets bigger and bigger and
bigger meaning
it is a model that works well for a
country of 30 million people
50 million people but maybe not 335
million people
no it works great i mean the founding
fathers i think they guessed that maybe
it would last 200 years
uh but the problem is
the the safeguards get eroded away
right they that because of
the the elements of democracy that creep
into the republic
once you get to a point where people can
vote themselves benefit from government
you're that's the beginning of the end
right and and it took a long time and we
created a lot of wealth
as a republic and it's taken a while for
a democracy to destroy that wealth
but that is human nature i mean so maybe
if we can one day change human nature
uh you know greed and envy and you know
a lot of people too who are skeptical of
human beings you know they're skeptical
of
capitalists they think that they're
greedy businessmen that's fine
greed is fine uh when you're an
entrepreneur because the only way you
can make money in a free market
is through voluntary exchange yes you
could cheat you could commit fraud and
there's laws against that
but to really succeed in a free market
economy
your success is measured by how much you
help other people
you have to convince them to buy your
products or your services
and and you have to provide it better
than your competitor
and if you do that and if you make other
people's lives better they will reward
you and you'll get rich
the problem is greedy people also go
into government they go into politics
and there their greed can be very
harmful because that's not about
voluntary interactions
they have the power of government they
can force you to do things uh using the
power of the state
and what happens is those greedy people
those evil people go into government
and then they enrich themselves by
impoverishing others
capitalists enrich themselves by
enriching others
the bureaucrats enrich themselves by
impoverishing others
but they also help enrich certain people
that that that perpetuate their
their their their incumbency and you
know so they reward those that help them
and it's an incestuous system and yeah
it's a problem
you know the key is to limit democracy
so you don't have all this uh voting for
theft
voting to steal things from other people
uh and and if you do that if you have
liberty
if you protect private property then
everybody will prosper and of course
people want to say well peter what about
the poor people who fall through the
cracks yes
let private charity help the poor people
that fall through the cracks because
there's always going to be those people
in a capitalist economy there's far
fewer of them
because there's a lot more opportunity
and prosperity but when
individuals voluntarily help other
individuals it's much more efficient
than when the government does it the
government taxes somebody a dollar
and by the time the money gets to the
intended recipient there's only
10 cents left private charity they
collect a dollar
they spend 10 cents on it and 90 cents
goes to the to the people that need it
so government is not efficient at
anything
especially helping the poor the
government
and then then the government perpetuates
poverty
because the government wants people to
be poor because that's how they get them
to vote for them it's hey you're poor
and i'm giving you money now i've bought
your vote see if it wasn't for me
you would starve because you wouldn't
get these welfare checks see that's the
government the government cripples you
and then claims credit for giving you a
crutch the free market makes it so you
don't need a crutch
by the way what are your thoughts i mean
i know you're more on the economy side
do you have any opinions on coronavirus
and the handling of it the shutting down
all that stuff what are your thoughts
about what's going on right now
yeah i mean look i i hear a lot of
things and
of course i'm generally skeptic
skeptical of
anything that happens and i certainly
agree
that regardless the government is using
this situation to expand its power
and to diminish individual rights that
will
haunt us you know for a long time just
like 911
right the 911 was a tragedy but the
bigger tragedy
was our response we did more damage to
ourself with the patriot act
and things like that anti-money
laundering we destroyed our liberties
not the terrorists
the terrorists won based on the
legislation
that we enacted during the hysteria
that surrounded those attacks and we're
still suffering we're still
suffering a lower standard of living uh
because of
uh the way the government took advantage
and exploited that crisis
to make the government bigger and to
diminish our freedoms and therefore our
prosperity
so the same thing is happening now and i
am very worried about
the rules that are going to be put into
place as the economy is
you know reopened what are the new
requirements that are going to be put on
businesses
uh that are going to undermine their
productivity that are going to increase
the cost of maki of running a business
and employing people
and serving the public what other rights
are we gonna lose
uh going forward to give the government
more power
to supposedly protect us uh from future
uh pandemics uh but as far as the
coronavirus itself look
i don't know uh i i i i tend to believe
that maybe they're making a mountain out
of a mole hill here
uh that the coronavirus may not be any
worse
than an ordinary influenza uh that
they're exaggerating
the numbers that people are dying that
happen to have
coronavirus and now we're blaming it on
coronavirus
when there are other factors that are as
important or maybe more important
and that there's a lot of people who
have the disease who
are not uh you know in the statistics
because they have such a mild case of it
that we don't know about them
that if we actually you know looked at
the whole population
that the percentage of death is actually
very small
because we have so many people who have
it who aren't even showing symptoms so
we don't even
get them into statistics so uh there's a
good chance that this whole thing is
overblown but i i
i also get the fact that maybe it's not
and a lot of us are just taking you know
what
even though i think it's a bunch of bs
i'm i'm not going to take any chances
you know maybe they're telling the truth
maybe it is as bad as they're saying
so you know what i'm not going to go out
to the restaurants i'm not going to
travel as much
just just in case even though i think
it's probably bs
and even though i think i'd probably be
fine you know who knows
maybe you know maybe you know so they've
got everybody so scared
that even people like me who are like
looking at this is probably [ __ ]
so then that means their formula of fear
tactics is working on somebody like you
who typically
questions everything yeah well it's
working all over the world i mean
you know it's like you know it's like
why take any chances you know
it's like look you know people you don't
have to there are a lot of things you
don't have to do
you can just decide i won't do that i
mean i'm uh better safe than sorry
right and so if a lot of people are
making these decisions
obviously it's it's a huge impact uh on
economic activity
where people are deciding that they have
to alter their behavior and that's why i
think that even when
the government gives everybody the all
clear
people are still going to be nervous and
they are not going to uh interact
in you know social scenes to the extent
that they did before at least for
maybe a year or two right and so that's
going to have lingering effects on a lot
of these businesses
that have been bailed out that are
probably going to be in need of
continuous
uh bailouts but of course the problem is
when all the money that we're
we're using collapses right everybody
can get a check from the government
but what happens when that check doesn't
buy anything that's the crisis that's
coming
but what is that check you know what the
check is nothing to a guy making 130
grand a year that's only got 93 000
saved in a bank and he's uh going
through his money very quickly that's
that's not a lot of money yeah
i mean the people the people who were
higher earners
who were living uh on the edge right
they were you know
they're they're suffering the people who
are actually better off
are lower income people who are now
earning more money
being unemployed than they were where
they had to work
and there's a big difference between
just getting a check
and having to actually go to work i mean
most people don't enjoy working
plus you have the commute time and all
the other ancillary expenses
and then they tax you so there are a lot
of americans
that are making a lot more money now
that don't want
the economy back why would they want
their lousy jobs back when they're
making more money
and they have more leisure uh and now a
lot of them don't even have to pay their
rent it's okay not to pay your rent
it's okay not to make your mortgage and
by the way we're going to give you even
more money
than when you were paying your rent so
this is a windfall for a lot of people
who are going to want to perpetuate this
gravy train you know and so a lot of
these programs are going to be extended
because now we've created this
constituency
just like with social security the
government hooks everybody on a ponzi
scheme
called social security instead of having
self-reliant people save for their own
retirement
we tax the hell out of them when they're
working and we tell them to rely on the
government ponzi scheme
but once you've got a bunch of people
who have none of their own retirement
savings
and the only thing they got is a
government promise
nobody will touch that you create that
third rail where you have all these
voters
that have been bought and paid for
because of social security we're now
doing that now on a bigger scale
by putting a lot of people on these
programs where their
their livelihood now is coming from the
government and we'll see if anybody has
the ability to take that away
so you have that class of people that's
actually making more money not being
productive
not working uh the people who are in the
middle or yeah the guys that were maybe
making 150 200 300 000 a year
their uh unemployment is not
supplementing
their incomes um and you know
but everything nobody should be getting
these these these checks
the a the government doesn't have the
money and printing the money doesn't
mean that we can afford it
because the cost of them should be
getting these checks
peter when you say nobody should be
getting these checks but
we should trust the shutdown if that's a
contradictory message because if
nobody gets to check yet we do shut down
then if they're not getting money
there's many here's the thing
getting money if the state governments
knew that there was no federal bailout
money coming
would they be shutting everything down
as aggressively as they are
or would they be doing more of a cost
benefit analysis i think it's because
everybody believes that we can shut down
and the government's just going to
provide all the money
and it's like okay let's play it safe
yeah but if you have to realize that
there is a financial cost
of these shutdowns then maybe we can do
it in a smarter way
which is what i said from the beginning
maybe it's the
older people who are not in good health
who have these other conditions that
should be
quarantined and young healthy people
should be going about their day
and maybe yes we could wear masks and
things like that but we should have to
make
viable economic decisions knowing the
cost and benefit of every decision we
make
if we operate under the false premise
that there's no cost
because all this money is coming from
free for the government
then we're not doing the right thing and
i think a lot of these state governments
too
that were already broke going into this
crisis because of bad
decisions they made they're now using
this as an excuse to say oh we need all
this bailout money oh you have to give
us this money now you can't let us go
bankrupt
it's kind of like a get out of jail free
card for a lot of states and
municipalities who want to milk this for
all it's worth
in a way i think they're kind of
intentionally doing this
to get more government money it's like
the worst they can
they can make it for themselves the more
money they think they're going to
qualify for
so if if nobody thought that there was
free money and we had a cost
then i think we would have a more
rational discussion
on what to do and the you know if
whether or not people don't pay their
rent or don't pay their mortgages
all of these decisions should be made
voluntarily
by the affected parties so landlords and
tenants
should make their own deal without the
government because look let's say i'm a
landlord and my
my my uh tenant is unemployed and he
can't pay his rent
in this environment if i kick him out am
i going to get another tenant right away
how long is my apartment going to be
empty anyway and if the guy was a good
tenant for years and years
there's value in that relationship
landlords and tenants
will work it out they worked it out
during the depression
there was roosevelt never said no one
has to pay their rent during the
depression
it was a depression it was 25
unemployment and they didn't say you
don't have to pay rent
but landlords some people couldn't pay
the rent they worked it out
so we can work stuff out uh borrowers
and and debtors employers employees they
can work it out
the problem is everybody's broke nobody
has any savings whose fault is that
the fed kept interest rates so low for
so long they punished savers
and they rewarded debtors so we got a
lot of debtors and we've no savers
how much how much uh i'm assuming you've
read the book uh uh
the the creature of jekyll island i'm
assuming you've read it
how about how much credence do you give
to that yourself are you from the school
of thought of ah i don't know about
the you know the the sixth man or
whatever it is that you got together how
much value do you give to that
look you know i i do not believe
that the federal reserve was started
with bad intent right and
and the federal reserve act the way
it was originally proposed and adopted
was not a bad act it was not right
the reason that the fed was created is
prior to the federal reserve
uh a lot of banks issued their own
currency which was all and all of it was
backed by gold
right uh but you know if you were out in
california
and somebody gave you a note from a
philadelphia bank how did you know the
note was good i mean yeah i mean there's
there were a lot of different notes that
were circulating at the time
and the idea was let's have one central
bank that we could rediscount all these
notes
take the notes right and reissue its own
notes so the federal reserve note
was supposed to be backed 100 percent by
notes of other banks
and 40 by gold and the theory behind
the the federal reserve 2 was to provide
an elastic money supply
and the idea at the time was that as the
economy expanded and contracted
the money supply would mimic the economy
so during good times when the economy
was expanding
the federal reserve would create money
and during times when the economy was
contracting during a recession
they would shrink the money supply right
the opposite of what they do now
so it was supposed to have an elastic
money supply
that reacted to the economy to kind of
smooth out
prices and to have a better quality of
currency uh that would be more
recognizable uh
and the original federal reserve act
the federal reserve was prohibited from
owning any u.s government debt
they couldn't own even treasuries that
was not even allowed
that was in the original act they
couldn't do it so
that act as originally intended was not
bad the problem was
the camel's nose under the tent the
reason not to do it
was because nothing stays good once you
allow
a central bank to form it gets corrupted
and it happened right away
because we we established the federal
reserve in 1913.
we got into world war one in 1917. the
minute we got into world war one
that's when the government wanted to use
the fed to help finance the war
and so they amended the federal reserve
act during world war one
to allow the federal reserve to own u.s
treasuries
so that we could finance world war one
see they used the crisis the emergency
of a war that we never should have
entered in the first place
we should have minded our own business
and never got involved in that war and
had we stayed out of world war one there
never would have been a world war ii but
that's the topic of a whole other
podcast
but because we got into war we were able
to
amend the federal reserve act and here's
an interesting fact that people don't
know
you want to know why we have a debt
ceiling we the debt ceiling came about
at the same time because what happened
was
politicians back in 1917 were worried
hey if we allow the federal reserve to
buy u.s treasuries
what if we what if the fed runs big
debts right
and so they said okay we'll have a debt
ceiling we'll limit
how much money the federal government
can borrow so we won't have to worry
about
the fed monetizing the debt but the
problem with the debt ceiling
is that if they could raise it so we
empowered the federal reserve
to monetize debt and we impo
imposed the debt ceiling at the same
time understanding how the two were
related
but then every time we hit the ceiling
we raised it
nobody ever had the guts not to raise
the ceiling see when i ran for senate in
that was my campaign i was going to be
the vote to filibuster
the debt ceiling the buck was going to
stop with me no more increase in the
debt ceiling
to force the government to cut spending
see they always say we have to raise the
debt ceiling
because america always pays its bills
right if we don't raise the debt ceiling
we can't pay our bills the reason we
raise the debt ceiling is because we
never pay our bills
we we go into debt instead of paying our
bills i wanted to force
the country to pay its bills by not
raising the debt ceiling by saying okay
no more borrowing so we got to pay our
bills or admit that we can't
we have to default or whatever but we're
going to start to be to be honest but
that's how we got the debt ceiling
so i don't think that it was created in
the as a conspiracy for an evil purpose
i think it's another example of the road
to hell
being paved with good intentions and why
we never should have had a central bank
because the people who opposed the
central bank like andy jackson who got
rid of the first
central bank right it's because they
understand
the potential for abuse right the
founding fathers knew
that paper money in central banking was
a bigger threat to our liberty
than the armies of other nations right
we destroyed ourselves
and i think money central banking also
the supreme court
has done a lousy job of enforcing the
constitution
so they've let us down uh as that branch
of government judiciary
has been a big failure uh but the
central bank i mean
that has been probably the biggest
problem with hollowing out our economy
and placing us in this predicament that
we're in now do you believe the most
powerful man in the world is still the
president of the united states
well obviously the president has a lot
of power but probably the
the fed might have even more power for
now but that power is going to go away
when the dollar collapses and the u.s
dollar is no longer
the reserve currency uh then the power
is going to collapse with it i mean we
still have a military obviously
but the soviet union had a big military
what happened to it it crumbled
right because the soviet union uh was
also a mirage
uh the same as the united states i mean
you know we exist based on debt it's a
debt bubble
and it's the world that is financing it
the world is making this possible
uh by accepting the dollar as the
reserve currency and living beneath its
means so that we can live above our
means
the world has to produce extra so that
we can consume
the world has to save money and lend it
to us instead of using it productively
in their own economy so we're basically
a parasite right now
feeding off the global economy as soon
as they realize
this and and and want to extricate
themselves from this
uh you know relationship uh then the
power of the united states is going to
implode
so the most powerful person in the world
today you're saying is the
is the fed the powell is more powerful
than the president
well i think i think if powell did the
right thing
uh you know but you know trump could do
the right thing too
you know trump could trump could stop
the spending
he doesn't have to sign uh these uh uh
these
government uh bailouts and these
deficits i mean all he needs all trump
needs
is uh a third of the the senate a chunk
of the republicans to stand with him
and he could shrink government i mean
trump could do the right thing right now
if he wants to the problem is he doesn't
get elected though he will not get
re-elected though
who cares he's probably not going to get
re-elected anyway but why did we elect
trump
trust that's been set up in america
though the system in america is
when you become a president on first
term don't push the envelope too much
push it on the second one because
you know this it's not like i'm the
first one telling you this if you push
too much on the first one you won't get
reelected
but you know what when they get
re-elected they don't do anything either
look if if i ever had the opportunity to
be president
i would not be planning on my second
term i don't guess you don't know if
you're going to get one
i would want to do it all in my first
term and trump
had the opportunity for his first two
years when he had the republican
congress
that's when he could have leveled the
public and used his political capital
to do the right thing to step above
politics and to level with the american
public
instead he as soon as he became elected
he became another politician
and all he cared about was getting
having a second term
and he was willing to sacrifice
everything that got him his first term
in order to buy the second term well i
mean he had to debate this russia deal
for the entire time so that that that
made it pretty
uh annoying when you're going in and
you're kind of trying to fight off
something else
but gold standard okay i know you're a
big fan of going back to the gold
standard
if if we do decide to go back on the
gold standard how do we do that
well we're going to go back on the gold
standard eventually you know it's not
going to be our decision it's going to
be the market's decision
i think the world is likely to go on the
gold standard
before we do even though we still
supposedly have a lot of gold because
the u.s dollar is now the world reserve
currency before the dollar was the
reserve currency
gold was the monetary reserve right and
we changed that at you know in
in brentwood but the reason we were able
to get the world
to follow us onto the dollar standard
was because at the time the us was the
world's richest creditor nation
we had massive trade surpluses or big
creditor nation
uh and we had all the gold we had all
the factories we were the big producer
of manufactured goods
low-cost producer of everything
manufactured was made in america
so we had a powerful economy a real
wealthy economy and the dollar was not
only backed by gold but it was
convertible
into gold americans couldn't convert it
anymore thanks to fdr
but foreigners if you had 35 dollars
federal reserve notes
you get an ounce of gold and so what we
told all the central banks
around the world was hey back your
currencies
with dollars instead of gold because the
dollar is as good as gold because 35
are one ounce of gold but the difference
is if you have 35 dollars
you can buy a us treasury and earn
interest
right but still have a gold standard
because we got your gold at fort knox
and so the the world made that deal with
us
but of course once they made that deal
we exploited it because now all of a
sudden we convinced the world to hold
treasuries as reserves
to loan the us government money so we
could spend more but what really
happened during the 1960s
is we abused that we really started
running big deficits
because we didn't have to have the gold
anymore we can just print money
and everybody was holding on to it so we
had uh the great society the war on
poverty vietnam the moon mission
we had the guns and butter and we
printed all this money
and um then we started you know our
creditors got smart
de gaulle and france in particular
wanted his gold is this [ __ ] you
don't have any
you know you know and in fact prices
really started to go up because of all
the money we were printing but the price
of gold wasn't going up all the other
prices were going up
and so it was clear that gold was
undervalued and so the world
wanted their money and and then we went
off the gold standard instead of doing
the right thing
which would be to devalue the dollar
officially to a point that
the gold price would make sense or to
allow deflation
so that prices would come down back in
line with a 35
gold price we did the worst thing
possible we went off the gold standard
and the price of gold went up to 850 we
had all the inflation of the 1970s
we really you know had a terrible a
decade
uh but even though the dollar got marked
down dramatically it lost two-thirds of
its value against the the swiss franc
the
d-mark uh the yen uh the dollar
continued to function as the reserve
currency despite the fact that it was
backed by nothing
right now once that happened we really
abused that
then we started running massive deficits
because we didn't have to have any gold
and no
everybody knew that we didn't have any
gold and we just kept printing money
and then we developed this completely
phony economy
this service sector economy that was
based on the ability to print money and
just
send it abroad and the world sent us all
our stuff that we didn't have to produce
and now no one had to save anything
because we could just rely on the
foreign savings
but when the dollar crashes and it's
going to because this system has
screwed up the entire global economy um
then the world is not just going to
anoint some other currency as the king
right we're not going to have
the euro as the reserve currency or the
yen or
the chinese r b uh none of that right
we're just going to go back to gold gold
works
as money and gold is a viable reserve
for currency and that's why a lot of
central banks still hold gold
and that's why central banks have been
buying gold is because they are
preparing
for a return to a goal-based monetary
system
that works instead of this fiat system
that doesn't but that principally
benefits the united states
the united states benefited because we
were the monopolist
in the creating of the dollar we got to
print them and so we got this
extraordinary privilege
but in the process we have hollowed out
our economy
so when we lose that privilege we're
going to have a huge price to pay
we are very vulnerable because of you
know
of of this system but in the long run i
mean we'll we'll benefit too from a
return to the gold standard
but that's what's going to happen and
and so
and the way you go back to a gold
standard is you simply announce
right that your currency is now tied to
gold
at a particular rate and obviously that
rate is going to be a function of how
much gold you have
and how much currency is in circulation
but obviously the gold price for the u.s
to return to a gold standard at this
point
i don't know if it's ten thousand
fifteen thousand twenty thousand i don't
know where we have to fix the price of
gold to make it work
in dollars but we can do it but then
once you get on a gold standard you got
to stay on a gold standard
that means the budget has to be balanced
that means trade
has to be balanced right be we we can't
run these big budget deficits we can't
run these big trade deficits
so now all of a sudden gold is going to
force
fiscal responsibility on our elected
officials which is what they don't want
that is the opposition that is why
government doesn't want the gold center
because they don't want
uh that kind of restraint it's like dude
if if you're at a high school prom
did the kids want the chaperones there
of course not they don't want the
chaperones there they want to have fun
they don't want the chaperones
uh and so the politicians don't want
chaperones
at their prom they don't want gold
ruining their party
they want to be santa claus they want to
get they want to promise something for
nothing
when you're on a gold standard you can't
print gold
it has to be mined out of the ground
right
so then the question becomes to go back
to gold standard
the history of it if you can help me out
with this part here i think it was what
fdr went on gold standard he asked
people to bring back the gold and they
were you know compensated i don't know
we were the we were on a gold standard
from the constitution
and in fact the constitution established
both gold and silver as money so we're
on a buy metallic standard
right so the dollar was actually defined
as a weight of gold or silver that was
the definition of a dollar
right it's a it's a measurement of how
much gold or silver that you have right
and that's where it came from and it was
actually
it was named from the spanish mill
dollar which was a coin
that was uh circulating around the time
of the revolution
and in fact during the revolution uh we
did have paper money
right the government issued continental
uh money that was actually backed
by gold uh but they issued too much of
it and it ended up collapsing and and
people got 10 cents on the dollar
and it gave way to the expression not
worth the continental
uh which is one of the reasons that the
founding fathers when they established
the united states
did not want paper money and so they
specifically banned it
if you understand how the constitution
is written you'll see that paper money
is illegal in the united states
they said gold and silver are legal
tender they said no state can make
anything other than gold and silver
legal tender
and the only power they gave to congress
was the power to coin money which is
gold and silver
they didn't give congress the power to
emit bills of credit
which is paper money and they denied
that power to the states so
we there was no paper money and we had
no paper money at all in the united
states
until the civil war right so we went
until 1961
right without any paper money so if
paper money was constitutional
we would have had it before 1861. so we
got paper money
in 1861 and it was backed by gold the
greenbacks that were issued were backed
by gold
and they were they challenged it there
were several
supreme court cases because people said
hey this is unconstitutional
you can't print money even if it's
backed by gold
and if you read some of these supreme
court decisions the reason they said it
was constitutional
was not because of the monetary powers
that were given to congress everybody
knew that they had no power to print
money
they looked to the necessary and proper
clause and said we were in a civil war
it was an emergency and so it was an
emergency wartime power
if the government could requisition
goods in a war
they could requisition goods and give
you a paper iou
so it was because it was a war and there
was an emergency
that we were able to issue the paper
money back by gold
and then what happened was after the war
ended they stopped doing it
they i mean they've been they so the
paper money didn't even come back
until the federal reserve brought it
back in 1913
right and we were still on a gold
standard i said federal reserve notes
had to be backed by
by real money in fact federal reserve
notes were not dollars federal reserve
notes were ious
four dollars the dollars were the gold
that the federal reserve had
a coin right that's a dollar an ounce of
gold
is a dollar right a 20 gold piece about
an ounce of gold
is 20 the dollar is the gold and silver
the piece of paper the federal reserve
note which is why it's called
a note is it's a note because it pays
the bearer
dollars the real money the notes aren't
the money the dot the gold and silver
was the money so we were still on
a gold standard and then what happened
is when
the depression hit right stock market
crashed
uh and roosevelt i mean hoover made all
his mistakes of
hoover was like the george bush of his
day with big bailouts and stimulus
his own version uh to turn that downturn
into what became the great depression
had we handled the 1929 downturn the way
we handled the 1920 downturn
had we done nothing had we just cut
government spending and let the free
market work
there never would have been a depression
and we never would have elected
roosevelt but because
uh hoover uh intervened for political
reasons
and made the situation worse uh we ended
up with hoover
and believe it or not hoover campaign i
mean roosevelt campaigned against hoover
by campaigning against the deficits that
he ran the big deficits
and saying you know he's he's
intervening too much he was like trump
he kind of ran
criticizing the big government policies
of hoover but then when he won
he adopted the entire agenda with the
new deal and
and and made it and made it even worse
but one of the things that
uh roosevelt wanted to do was he wanted
to increase government spending and the
gold standard stood in the way
so rather than just abandoning the gold
standard he said
it's illegal to own gold everybody has
to turn in their gold
right so everybody turned in their gold
they're not everybody but a lot of
people
and the government gave everybody 25
right for for an ounce and then as soon
as roosevelt got everybody's gold
he devalued the dollar and said now you
need thirty five dollars to buy an ounce
of gold so that's how the he
they took all that money because they
they had to devalue the dollar but they
wanted to get all the gold first
right and then they used that to fund a
lot of the the government programs
but we stayed on a gold standard even
though we devalued the dollar
we stayed on the gold standard and it
was illegal still
to own gold because the government in
order to get everybody's gold
they had to make it illegal to own it
and it stayed illegal to own gold until
the early in the 1970s
it was illegal um but even
when the government made it legal again
and you could always own gold jewelry
you just couldn't own it in a monetary
form
you could have a necklace made of gold
or you could have silverware you know
made of gold
but you just couldn't have a bar a
bullion or a coin
um but certain collectors coins you're
allowed to have
they couldn't take your coin collection
but what happened was
when they when they made it legal again
to own gold it wasn't remonetized
because now we were totally off the gold
standard
we didn't leave the gold standard
completely until 1971
when nixon you know said that's it but
the reason we went off the gold standard
was because nixon had a choice
cut government spending right or
sever the link to gold because we were
reaching the point where we could not do
it anymore
we were going to have to act responsibly
right
or to continue to be reckless but the
only way to do that was to get off the
gold standard
but the politicians want to pretend that
oh the gold standard is bad
the gold standard is good you know they
say oh if we're on a gold standard
we can't stimulate the economy in a
recession exactly
because the stimulus doesn't work it's
actually a sedative
the government causes the recessions
with the policies that it uses to get us
out of the last recession
and instead of allowing the free market
to cure the economy
government intervention makes it sicker
so
if if somebody does believe that we're
going to go back on gold standard would
this be a good time to buy gold
absolutely look we can't go back on a
gold standard
at the current price of gold the price
of gold is going to have to be
much higher why is that yesterday why is
that
but because it did look at all the money
that's in circulation i mean look
the other way to do it is if the price
of everything else goes down
so if we allow complete deflation if we
allow prices to collapse and gold stays
the same
then then it can still work but it has
to do with relative and in deflation the
government would destroy
a lot of the money that's in circulation
so we can go back to a gold standard
through massive deflation i just don't
think that that that's politically
expedient
i think the easiest way to go back to a
gold standard is just to revalue the one
price of gold
up to me to match everything else uh
but either way if you own gold you win
either way
right if the price of gold goes up way
up then you have more purchasing power
if the price of gold stays the same and
real estate crashes stocks crash
then you're still have more purchasing
power right you could still buy more
stuff
with your gold so regardless of how we
go back to a gold standard
if you have more gold now you are the
winner right
the central banks that are adding to
their gold holdings now
their nations will be winners right it's
the central banks that were dumb enough
to sell their gold
that still haven't bought any back uh
those are the you know
ridiculously foolish decisions you're a
pro gold guy so then the uh
the other question would be when is it
bad time to buy gold
well look as a trader look obviously
after a big spike it's probably not the
best time to be a trader
but as far as if you don't own any gold
the best time to buy some is right now
because it's like
you know what if you don't own any
insurance you know what if you have a
house
when's the best time to buy your
insurance policy just go out and buy it
because
you don't have insurance you know if you
have a family that depends on you
you don't have life insurance when's the
best time to buy it
you better buy it now right i mean now
if i knew exactly when
uh i was gonna die well then i i would
could buy it the day before
but since you don't know that right gold
is insurance
so you need to have it you need to own
it so if you don't own any gold
you buy some today doesn't matter the
price now do you buy
all that you can afford no keep a little
powder dry buy some more if it goes down
and in the future
if you have more money but people should
have five or ten percent of their money
in gold
but as they earn more money they need to
buy more gold right because now you have
a bigger portfolio
that you need to to protect so you know
my company is shift gold
i think i got the best prices if you
don't believe me just shop around
don't buy numismatics you know that's
not a gold investing that's
a coin collector this is not the time to
start a coin collection
you just want to own bullion that's the
cheapest way uh to acquire
gold or silver uh so people should do
that you know and
you know i i think the mining stocks are
really good investments because i think
that they don't reflect
uh what's gonna happen that's more
speculative uh but i think you know
people should be buying and i've been
telling people to buy gold
for over 20 years when i started
recommending it as a broker
gold was under 400 an ounce it was
actually under 300 for a while but i
didn't really start buying it for my
clients until it was in the
threes i started buying silver it was
under five bucks
it's around 15 now it got as high as 50
uh in 2011. i think it's going much
higher than that in this bull market
so are you more bitcoin or are you more
gold well i'm i don't have any bitcoin
at all i mean i
i i don't think uh the crypto currencies
are going to
work i think they're fool's gold i think
that they're they're
speculative vehicles i think there are a
lot of people who think uh
that bitcoin is gold uh because it's
replicated
some of the properties that made gold a
better money than other commodities that
have functioned his money
but it misses the point the most
important point of any
uh money is its intrinsic value
the reason that gold worked as money is
because of the inherent value of the
metal
uh its properties as a metal and the
fact that it has so many uses
uh it's the most useful metal on the
planet uh whether it's uh for
conducting electricity uh all the other
applications it has that makes it
such a good metal for jewelry or you
know or other applications
uh you know gold is valuable and gold
can store that value indefinitely
uh which is why it's so good as money
and it has other properties
as far as uh its liquidity and its
divisibility and its durability and its
immutability and there's a lot of things
a lot of characteristics that make gold
better money
than salt or cattle or you know or
wampum or cigarettes or different things
that could function as money
but what what what gives paper money
value
is the real money that backs it up right
because fiat money doesn't have any
value on its own
unless it's tied to something real but
bitcoin has no actual value there's
there's
you can't do anything with a bitcoin
there is no
real world demand for bitcoin yes you
can sell it to somebody else
but they'll only buy it if they think
the price is going to go up but somebody
will only buy it from them if they think
somebody will pay more
but the minute you run out of greater
fools the pyramid implodes and that's
really what we have
i feel badly for a lot of people who are
going to lose a lot of money
uh who have bought into this uh pyramid
uh but a lot of people who got in early
uh who are smart enough to get out will
make a lot of money if they're smart
enough to
to convert that those paper profits into
gold then they'll keep the money
they'll keep the purchasing power but
you've been an entrepreneur before
multiple times you have businesses you
you've done well for yourself whether it
was companies i mean i read somewhere
where
i think for like a three year span your
salary per year you were making
somewhere around 17 million
a year i don't know if that's accurate
or not but it's it's said that you've
made some
legitimate money you've done well for
yourself well all the money
all the money i've made has been
legitimate i haven't stopped when i say
legitimate i mean believe me i've
interviewed mobsters i don't mean that's
my
money i'm talking about like you've made
money like you're not somebody that has
opinions that just wrote wrote a couple
of books
well i and then you started giving your
opinions yeah look
this is the question i was going to ask
you if you're the 35 year old leadership
today
you're running a small business you got
employees
you you got you got you know the
challenges you're facing with shutting
down
what would the 35 year old pedo shift be
doing in today's economy
well i mean you know if if i had
my business which you know my business
was very small when i was 35.
and that's perfect that's the person
that i i want that person's counselor
i could have easily never i did the
first two years that i ran my business
i didn't even earn any money i had no
income i had to spend all
my revenue on my rent on my salaries
and the reason i was able to go into
business is because i had personal
savings
uh and how did i get personal savings
when i worked uh
for an employer like sears and lehman
like we discussed
and i earned money i didn't spend most
of it i saved it right
and and so i was able to use my savings
to start my own business
and i was able to survive on those
savings and some profits i had from
on investment i had invested early on in
some cellular phone deal and i made some
money there
back in the days where they were
lottering off the sell signals
so i had some income from an investment
i had some savings from work
and that was able to tie me over for a
couple years where i earned no money
um and and and i started a business but
you know so
i was already used to earning no money
at one point i mean if
if i would have maintained as i i've
always had i've always maintained my
business in a way
that i can go without revenue that i i
you know i and as an entrepreneur as a
businessman
that is a risk that you take as an
entrepreneur is you may not get any
money
but you may have to be on the hook for
all costs of
costs and so that's part of what you do
as a business
is that you you have reserves and i've
always operated my businesses where
if i don't earn any income i'm fine i
can
cover my overhead with my past income i
can use that right
now obviously taxation diminishes
people's ability to do that
uh but you can still do that but i you
know i i would not be looking for
a government bailout my look i didn't
take any of this money they got like
i could have i could have signed up and
i could have got a bunch of money
i have several businesses that have
employees that i have no intention of
firing so i could have got all this free
money
but the problem is you know i don't i i
knew i didn't need the money so i didn't
want to
stay to the government i need the money
but look i'm i don't want to pay taxes
i'm in puerto rico now
right when when i was making a lot of
that big money uh
back back back then i was half of it was
going to the government so i made a lot
of money but i
i have the government took half now the
government's not taking any at least the
federal government or very little of it
uh and so uh you know now i'm able to
keep keep what i hear but i'm earning
the money i'm earning it legitimately
by providing services that people are
voluntarily paying me to provide
uh you know my my main business is asset
management where i manage people's money
uh through individual accounts through
my mutual funds uh which people can you
know go to
your pacificfunds.com to check out my
mutual funds or europe pacific capital
your pac.com uh to look at having a
counseling i have a bank here your
pacific bank you know
shift gold where we sell gold so i i'm
in the market competing with other gold
companies you know i compete with other
broker dealers and banks and asset
management companies and obviously there
are people who choose to do business
with me
uh when they could do business with
somebody else but they choose to do
business with me
but but i think it's something that's
very powerful though you said something
that's very powerful i think the small
business owner the entrepreneur can take
that
it's it's not what you're doing today
that matters it's what you did a year
ago two years ago three years ago to
prepare yourself for a crisis like a
time like this where you can at least
survive during times like this because
yeah and people forget you know when
everybody thinks
it's easy to be the businessman like oh
it's not fair
you know the workers you know they need
to share in the profits
the workers don't share in the risks you
know when
when people take a job right the easiest
thing you could do
is accept a job from somebody else
because now they are on the hook
with paying you right they have to
figure out how to cover the pay
right you're you get a guaranteed salary
right where the employer is going to pay
you
every friday or every other friday
whether he's got a profit or not when
you own a business
you are the last one to get paid that's
right you only get paid after you've
paid everybody else
you've paid your workers their wages you
paid the landlord the rent if you
borrowed money you paid interest to your
lenders
right only if there's something left
over do you make any money and that is
the risk
that the entrepreneur is rewarded for
taking because
you set a business you have no idea if
you're going to succeed or fail yeah and
so if you succeed
you need to be paid for that but you
also then
are responsible as you're making money
not to just spend it all
workers okay if you're going to live
paycheck to paycheck that's on you
but if you're the employer and you're
living paycheck to paycheck you're
putting all of your workers at risk
you're putting your whole company at
risk
so you don't do that you save your money
but you know you have the federal
reserve and the government coming in
and encouraging debt encouraging
encouraging leverage
screwing up uh the system but the
entrepreneur deserves
what he earns but if he's not
responsible enough
uh to be a steward of capital and and
prepare for
potential downturns which always come
then
the free market will clean house and
what happens is
you learn by example when people go
bankrupt
not only does that send a message to the
person who went bankrupt
but to all the other people of what what
you don't do here's an example of what
not to do
because if you run your business like
this you can lose your business
you can go bankrupt but what we're doing
now is we're rewarding the people
who were reckless by bailing them out
and then we're telling the people who
weren't reckless you were a bunch of
chumps
why were you saving for a rainy day just
wait for the government to bail you out
we're going to do the same thing with
the state governments if we bail out all
these states
that should fail not only are we sending
the bad message to those states
keep acting irresponsibly we're telling
the responsible states you're a bunch of
morons you guys are idiots
for acting responsibly cut taxes
government spending because why should
you be frugal because you're just going
to be bailed out we're going to just tax
the other states
uh to cover your proficiency very weird
i mean you saw harvard took 8.55 million
dollar
check themselves from uh the bailout and
lakers took 4.6 million and then after a
bunch of people talk smack to the lakers
they gave the money back
and uh they said yeah we don't need the
money by the way in 30 seconds
peter who were you in high school if i
was if i was in high school with you 16
years old who was the 16-year-old peter
schiff
well you know i had my father had a lot
of influence on me
as far as my thinking erwin shift and
understanding economics
austrian economics uh iran you know the
constitution so
i had a lot of uh my political
philosophy
even even back then just like my own my
oldest son who's now 17.
you know he's done a lot of reading and
because of me i've put him on the right
uh path and then he's you know kind of
traveled uh pretty far down that path
himself so
yeah i i i've i've had uh my uh
political feelings and my economic
understanding for almost my entire life
and so i do have a lot of respect for
people who didn't have the advantage
that i did of having a father like i had
because a lot of people start out when
they're younger
uh they're they're very socialist which
is a natural thing to be
uh you know because you're you're ruled
by your emotions and you're
caring and and you don't have the real
world experience to understand
all of the negative consequences
of all the well-intentioned uh programs
so a lot of people
start out as a liberal start out
socialist and they have to learn they
have to evolve
they have to experience life and and
then get
experience in in into intellect and
learn
to realize that all the ideas they had
when they were young were wrong
that they were well intentioned but
wrong because
intentions isn't what counts it's the
outcome that's what liberals still don't
understand
right they they can have a
well-intentioned law like the minimum
wage
and not understand the unintended
consequences of impoverishing the people
that you're trying to help
of throwing people out of work of making
it impossible
for non you know low skilled people to
get skills and earn more money i mean
people can't
can't get behind yeah but this guy is
not earning enough money so let's just
let's just pass a law so that he'll earn
more and not understand the consequence
of that law is that he earns less
or he earns nothing uh and so but
so other people have had to uh make that
evolution
of thought right they started off over
here and they had to come over here
on their own i i started off here i was
already here
so i have more respect for people who
had to make that journey
right who had to question what they once
believed and overcome that
which you know and there's an old
political saying right if you're not
liberal by the time you're 22 you don't
have a heart
if you're not a conservative by the time
you're 28 you don't have a head
uh and and those sayings they're free
you know and that's why
a lot of people on the left think that
conservatives or libertarians
are mean right because they just they're
just against these programs because
they're mean
it's not that we're mean it's that we
understand
that they don't work that they're that
they backfire see the liberals don't
understand that they actually think the
programs work
so that's why conservatives don't think
liberals are mean
they just think they're foolish but
liberals are convinced that
conservatives are actually mean bad
people
that they want to deny all this
government help
what we're denying is the problems that
that health creates
the dependency and the poverty that it
perpetrates the liberals just haven't
had that epiphany yet
they never made that journey their kids
like they never grew up they're like
little kids that believed in santa claus
and now they're adults and they still
believe
we're uh i love that part by the way
where by the way your father the more i
read about your father your father is a
very very unique human being you know
what he did and his
level of conviction in certain areas a
lot of respect for that man
i can only imagine what it was like
being around him and he's sharing his
philosophies with you and his teachings
with you
uh uh i bet that was he was a great guy
a patriotic guy uh really you know did
what he thought was right for his
country and he paid
the ultimate price for that as dying as
a political prisoner
uh in in in in the united states which
political prisoners do exist here my
father was one of them
uh he was in prison for his politics not
because he was a criminal
uh but yeah his books live on you know
you've got his website
paytonwincomtax.com is still there i
have some of his books at shiftbooks.com
some of his books you can download for
free on the internet you know his book
the federal mafia
we still have copies of it uh it shift
books but it was actually banned it's
the there's only been
two books in the history of america that
were ever banned by the federal
government
the first one was fanny hill which was
banned at 18 something
for being pornographic the next one was
my father's book the federal mafia
so it's a tr i don't know if it'll ever
make it on a trivial pursuit card
but uh that's hilarious uh uh uh
you know but uh galileo said in 1600 he
says the earth
revolves around the sun and they
arrested him so a lot of princess yes my
father used to point to galileo a lot
not to
equate himself to galileo to say that
i'm as smart as galileo
but just the fact that when people would
say well irwin you went to jail
well that doesn't mean he was wrong he
would say galileo went to jail
he wasn't wrong just because the
government put him in jail for saying
something doesn't mean that what he was
saying was wrong
and so my father said things that he
believed were right and i think many
cases were right
but the government put him in jail for
expressing those opinions
uh anyways respect your pops man it's
it's good that the legacy continues on
with you
and you're pushing the envelope i want
to do a speed round with you i'll give
you a name tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind i'm gonna give you a
name tell me the first thing that comes
to your mind
milton friedman he's a great economist
but i disagree with him on on money
ronald reagan the first uh president i
voted for
but i was very disappointed in him uh in
his and i voted uh libertarian
i voted for it was ron paul in uh when
he ran for reelection
uh because reagan and i had a i had a
poster of ronald reagan on my dorm room
wall as a freshman at berkeley yeah you
know in his cowboy hat and
in berkeley you know i was a big reagan
guy you know uh
wow and as a kid i mean i love reagan um
but i was disappointed because reagan
promised to get rid of the department of
energy the department of education cut
government spending
and he made the deal with tip o'neill
and government spending went up and the
deficits went up and
that frustrated me back then uh we got
the tax cuts that was the easy part
we didn't get the spending cuts and
initially there was a deal that he made
with tip o'neill it was supposed to be
two dollars
of uh of tax cuts for every dollar
of spending cuts rather you know for the
tax cuts and we never got to spending
cuts so
i was disappointed but look i i still
thought reagan was a great man
and i you know and he tried but somehow
he got to washington
and he got corrupted by that swamp alan
greenspan
uh he's uh he was the ace of spades in
the deck that created the financial
crisis so
i guess the word for him is traitor
that's the word i think of it
because i really liked greenspan as
he as a kid you know i mean because
greenspan he wrote that
brilliant piece uh in iran's book
capitalism the unknown ideal
uh gold and economic freedom and i still
have you can go to my website
uh shift radio and i posted up there
two letters that alan greenspan wrote me
in when i was in my 20s see
he had just become fed chairman in 87
and then we got the stock market crash
in october and the first thing he did is
he cut interest rates
and i thought that wait a minute you're
doing what you criticized the fed for
doing
in uh 1929 you you're making the same
mistakes right
and so i wrote him a very nice letter
and he wrote me back
you know on the fed you know the fed
sent me the letter
it was you know stamped you know because
federal reserve is not part of the
government
right so they have to pay for a stamp
it's not like a government agency it's
private
so they have to have to buy a stamp when
they send you a letter but it was his
signature he sent me a letter
and he kind of explained why he was
doing what he was doing
and i didn't i didn't like the
explanation but i said but you know and
i
and i wrote back and then he wrote me
again but basically
what greenspan said is look it's better
to do this and cushion the blow in the
short run
than to let the market you know he
basically he basically laid out
everything he was gonna do
uh for his entire tenure which was long
as far as trying to ease the short-term
pain and he
and and and and i knew it was a mistake
i knew as a
you know youngster that greenspan was
making mistake and i knew he knew it too
and and you know when you listen to
greenspan talk today i mean he sounds
you know he's predicting
stagflation like me and he was always
saying the debts were too big and we're
borrowing too much money
yet he enabled it i mean he was
criticizing the deficits as he was
the biggest enabler of the deficits by
keeping rates artificially low
uh and trying to prop up and sustain and
sustain bubbles so i was very critical
of greenspan in my book uh you know i
said he was the
uh the real architect of the housing
bubble
and the uh the primary reason that we
had a financial
crisis uh richard nixon one word
um well i already used traitor uh you
know
uh you know a disaster uh keynes i mean
he i mean he he was the one that said
we're you know
we're all uh keynesians now uh
took us off the gold standard uh you
know imposed
wage and price controls terrible
terrible
uh policy and you know i mean
he he was you know one of these you know
rockefeller republicans he represented
everything that was wrong
with the republican party that ronald
reagan tried to fix
um you know and and and the reason that
we got reagan was because
carter was such a disaster but carter
simply expanded
the policies that he inherited uh uh
from nixon
um and nixon just expanded on on on what
was happening under johnson
and you know so it was a perpetuation of
that
of that type of economy and reagan took
us away from that for a while
uh but yeah i know he was a bad
republican he helped give republicans a
bad name
uh and and and and you know took us off
the gold standard
which again was one of the worst uh
political decisions that was made and by
the way my father
my father testified in the senate
in 1968 against uh going off the gold
standard and
you know the secretary of the treasury
and the secretary of the federal reserve
or the chair of the federal reserve
testified in favor of it and
they said that if we went off the gold
standard the dollar would rise in value
and the price of gold would fall
my father said that the opposite would
happen that the dollar would lose value
the price of gold would go up and
inflation would surge right
my dad was the only one that was right
he knew exactly what would happen
if we went off the gold standard and the
secretary of the treasury
and the chairman of the federal reserve
were 100 wrong so at least we have that
consistency
because now the current secretary of the
treasury and the fed chairman
are 100 wrong and my father's son is out
there
sounding the alarm on what uh on what
the real consequences of these policy
mistakes are going to be
so frederick hayek and my father did my
father was an insurance agent
he he went to congress even more now
yeah he was insurance and see this is
the reason my father understood money
because my father went to congress and
said i sell
money for future delivery people are
buying insurance policies for me
where they're paying premiums today to
collect benefits tomorrow
and therefore the value of money is very
important
to my business because i'm selling money
for the future and so what it buys its
purchasing power is very important
and that's why he didn't want going off
the gold standard
because his customers his clients were
paying premiums
in gold he didn't want them being paid
benefits in paper
because if he didn't know what the paper
was going to be worth he knew it
it would depreciate which is exactly
what happened one
word frederick hayek he's a great man
okay great economist ludwig won mises
same thing brilliant brilliant man
michael bury well you know
uh you know i did that you know i mean
he's a smart guy too
uh you know i had the same trade on as
mike i didn't get as much uh
recognition uh and i didn't you know i
did i you know
uh so i think he i think he's a good guy
too you know and uh i like him
uh but you know i i it would have been
nice if you know
a little bit more people in the
mainstream would have recognized
uh you know my understanding of um of
the housing bubble
you needed a movie you needed a movie
yeah yeah i didn't get you know
i didn't get it i didn't get in the book
i didn't get in a movie
yeah uh but you know i was there i mean
you know i think
i was the one giving the lecture he you
know you watch the movie he attends i
was giving the lectures
about the housing bubble i was writing
articles
in 2002 3 4 5
writing about the bubble writing about
the mortgage market
writing about securitization writing
about subprime
saying it was going to collapse it was
going to implode it was a bubble i was
the guy trying to convince
everybody remember that that that that
so it
yeah i didn't get convinced i was the
one for all i know he
he he heard me i don't know how he
eventually how he's
initially gone he's an interesting guy
by bringing out
hundreds of emails to all the newspapers
for years
again watched that mortgage banker
speech on youtube
in 2006 and i and i was at that
convention in 2005 too
i wish i wish i had that on tape they
don't have that one i have the
oh six one but i told the same story in
2005 about
write a script let somebody do the movie
this
michael guy is a low-key guy who can't
stand the camera and he got the movie
jerome powell well he's another
disaster i mean you know um
he is he's maybe he's the fall guy i
don't know this could be the
it all all comes down i mean yellen got
out of dodge bernanke got out of dodge
you know greenspan minute
well i mean he he he's another one he's
another fraud i mean art
laffer arthur laffer my penny
i just think that penny he owes me hey
but
i mean it's not just the laffer curve on
that napkin of course you think of that
but i just think of the the the fact
that he that he welshed on that debt
and that he doesn't want to acknowledge
you know he still doesn't want to admit
that he lost
uh because he see laffer was too
partisan when bush was president to
recognize that we had a bubble and
that's the mistake a lot of republicans
make
they think if there's a republican
president who's cut taxes
they have to pretend that the economy is
great they can't tell the truth
that the economy is bubble but as i was
warning people back then
when the bubble pops then you have no
credibility if you're a cheerleader for
the bubble
because there's a republican president
then what do you do when it pops
you know and that's the problem now with
trump i mean i i voted for trump
i told people that he to vote for him
over over clinton
but i was very critical of him the
minute he started making mistakes i
didn't want to look the other way
just because he was a republican and not
a democrat and pretend that he was doing
good things when he was doing bad things
and he was telling me we had a great
economy when we just had a bigger bubble
aoc america's future hopefully not but
uh bernie sanders she just epitomizes
everything that's wrong with this
country
and it's the reason why we're not
supposed to be a democracy if you want
to know why
the founding fathers created america as
a republic and not a democracy
aoc ray dalio
oh well you know he's a smart guy
a very wealthy guy uh you know one of my
neighbors in uh in connecticut uh but
yeah i know he's uh you know i i
i agree with a lot of what ray says but
then they're you know there
there are things where we disagree i
mean i'm we're not friendly but i i know
i know of them are you by the way are
you related to adam schiff or no you
guys are not related
no no no in fact i joke that i i gotta
have to change my name you know it's
like he's really
he's really screwing up the name shift
you know yeah
i'm not related to jacob schiff either
the banker a lot of people assume that
i'm related to
although coincidentally my grandfather's
name was jacob schiff
but he was jacob schiff the carpenter
not jacob schiff
uh the banker i mean i would have loved
to inherited some of that shift money
uh you know my my branch of the shift
family
uh wasn't that successful uh you know
you inherited a good part of the
the the shift mindset your your pops
might well i learned that yeah you don't
just get that by osmosis yeah
my dad had had to teach me stuff but i
mean once your mind is open
i mean it's amazing how much you can
learn
once you're when you're not brainwashed
i mean the problem is we send these kids
through these government schools
and so by the time they're 22 they've
been so thoroughly brainwashed
you know that it's so hard for them i
mean even their common sense is gone
by the time they graduate so not only
are these college degrees
you know so expensive they're so
completely worthless because you end up
graduating knowing less than you knew
before you enrolled so
uh peter are you still uh would you
consider yourself a betting man
i'm not a big gambler i mean i i mean i
you know i mean
are you are you into better
announcements i i i enjoy uh
gambling you know but are you willing to
bet an ounce of gold
you said 70 to 80 biden
yeah i think i think biden is probably
going to win
uh you know do i i mean would i be
willing to bet an ounce a goal i think
the odds
are in my favor but they're not so
overwhelming in my favor that it's like
ah you know
this is the best bet i want to make with
an ounce of gold i've got various ounce
of gold bets going around here and there
i collected on one just recently from a
conference i did where
i we we made a bet of an ounce of gold
in january of 2019
and i bet the next move the fed would
make would be a rate cut
and the other guy better rate hike and
of course everybody thought he was going
to win
and i ended up winning because the fed
cut is this a bet you're willing to make
in this area or no this is not too high
i mean i can make it with you i mean
it's only an ounce of gold i
know but your thing is though i hope
here's the problem
i would rather see trump win so i hate
to
i hate to make a bet and then like hope
to win it you know what i mean because i
i just i just i i even though i know
it's going to be difficult if trump wins
even though i know that it's going to
implode around him
it's just that donald trump for all the
mistakes he's made
and all the things he's done wrong he
still has a better chance of eventually
doing
right then then that then um
then uh biden or whoever's going to
control biden i mean if i don't next
president let's face it
he's not the president he's just no you
want he's just the mouthpiece
somebody's gonna be pulling those
strings but he can't sell you
you need charisma nowadays once the
camera came out you need charisma like
if cuomo was out there
andrew cuomo was out there be a
different story because he knows how to
sell and command president
peter thank you for being a guest guys
what we're going to do is i'm going to
put all the links below to his books to
his site
uh he mentioned several sites mario
we'll put those below for people to go
find
and if you uh uh want to follow some of
his content make sure you go follow him
down he's got a youtube channel as well
you can yeah people there too yeah the
shift report
on youtube or shift radio from my
podcast
my listeners have been growing uh but
you know i need you know more and more
people to listen
i've been saying that since the
coronavirus uh has come on the scene
that the only thing spreading faster
than that virus is economic and
financial ignorance
and you're helping uh to do something
about that i think i got the anecdote
the cure for
uh that ignorance so the mainstream
media
has got everything wrong everything the
government is doing is wrong
everything the federal reserve is doing
if they only would do the george
costanza
uh and just do the opposite you know we
would be in much better shape
instead of they're doing what they think
is right but i'm i'm coming out there
and doing these podcasts and
and talking about what's happening in
the financial markets in the economy
and and telling the truth about it and
and kind of unspinning
uh what what the nonsense that people
are getting on a daily basis now
you got to keep doing it you got to keep
doing it more because there's many other
audiences that need to keep hearing you
peter again
thanks for getting being a guest thank
you for coming out so i want to hear
your thoughts on what you took away from
peter schiff's ideas and thoughts and
opinions about many different things and
again i got two videos i want you to
watch if you've still not watched the
ray value interview this is a great one
it goes with economy
uh which makes sense if you've not seen
before the other one is a video i just
recently did
which is about seven seven ways to grow
your business during the
global economic crisis and in there i
talk about three different types of
entrepreneurs so if you've not seen this
one click over here
if you want to see the ray value
interview click there and if you've not
subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]
you